[Music]
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between nando's in the uk and the us
this is food wars
[Music]
okay slight problem nando's is in the
u.s but it's only in four places
maryland illinois virginia and
washington dc now i'm in l.a baby i'm on
the wrong side of the mississippi but
luckily i have a colleague who is a
nando's enthusiast in chicago she
frequent nando's when she was living in
south africa and is perfect for taking
the u.s reigns for this episode of food
wars don't do food wars without eating
breakfast
i realize yeah i've made that mistake
several times
in the uk nando's chicken comes in three
serving sizes
a quarter of a chicken in the u.s
nando's standard chicken comes in just
two sizes there's a half a chicken
a whole chicken
or a fourth of a chicken
you can get a whole chicken in the u.s
but only as part of a platter and we're
going to weigh the whole chicken to see
which country's chickens are bigger usa
chicken baby
we can also get boneless thighs in the
uk if you order these they come in a
portion of four our thighs actually come
with a portion of three so we got one
two three
chicken chicken wings
they're my favorite thing and i'd love
to sing if you haven't already seen it
look up the nando's skank uh which is a
very pure distillation of british
culture in the late northeast it's ed
sheeran an example wrapping rapping
about nando's in a car park i don't know
why and then he's just flexing his black
card which i'm feeling about because you
know nando's black card
they give them out to select individuals
and it entitles you to free nandos which
i'm so jealous of also bone to pick with
that in general why do they always give
the celebrities the free stuff because
other people you need at least they're
already rich sort of guy out come on
i'm not a celebrity
not yet next up in the uk we've got
wings they come in four portions
a portion of three our wings come as a
serving of twelve a portion of five four
a portion of ten twenty four or a
portion of fifteen
if chicken on the bone isn't for you
nando's also offers chicken in the form
of burgers wraps and pitters in the uk
you can get these as singles
or as doubles
we can also get our chicken wrapped
or burgered
however in the us there's no option to
add double chicken
which sucks
it's like a little burrito
holy
don't do food words without eating
breakfast
i'm going to cry
we're going to remove all the toppings
from the single chicken burger and weigh
it to see how it compares to the us
version so we're going to take out the
tomato
and the lettuce
just like
harry mentioned which is good because
tomato does not belong on burgers and
never should
on the side of your chicken it's pretty
common to get some chips at nando's i'm
excited for this episode because i can
actually call them chips for once as
that's what they're referred to on the
us menu suck it joe suck it joel what
did i do why is everyone telling me
he's not even hosting this episode i
just can't
chips in the uk come in regular or large
sizes the standard us sizes are regular
and large
however if you get them as part of a
platter you can get the bonus extra
large size
let's weigh the large fries to see whose
is bigger
maybe i should have used the bowl
i'm still gonna eat these i don't care
if they touch all these gross
i'm getting too good at emptying brick
chips from containers so our scale is
just about adequate for this one and a
portion of large fries in the uk i said
fries why do i say fries i'm being
conditioned to saying fries that's right
buddy i heard you say fries this show is
getting to me a portion of large chips
in the uk comes to about 498 grams 150
grams
what about the biggest thing on each
country's menu well in the uk it's this
the family platter it comes with two
whole chickens five large sides and will
cost you 43 pounds and 70 pence the
biggest us item is the jumbo platter
it includes two whole chickens with two
extra large sides for 52.99
let's take a look at some of the
nutritional standouts from the nando's
menu if you were to get a standard meal
it might look something like this half a
chicken a portion of perry salted chips
and a portion of macho peas in the uk
this would come to a total of 1228
calories which honestly isn't too bad
there's also nothing really alarming on
that the only notable thing is that it
contains 186.4
of your daily protein intake over here
it comes out to 124
calories which is actually a little less
than the uk's version
our chicken in chips are actually a
little less calorific than the uk's but
for some reason our macho peas are more
calorific what's this dish
already i can tell there's a bunch of
like spices
and seasoning on the piece
i'm thinking butter is involved
oh
i hate peas
that is not what i was expecting
it does have a kick to it based on the
ingredients there's not really anything
alarming that we see in the us version
either there's just a lot of sodium in
it which is kind of expected because of
all the spices and the seasoning that
goes into it
one thing to watch out for is the
basting flavor of your chicken somehow
if you get your chicken as extra hot in
the u.s it adds 4
611 milligrams of sodium
that's double your daily allowance just
for the base that's so much sodium
that's insane what about the most
calorific thing on the uk menu well it
might not surprise you to learn that
it's actually a whole chicken extra hot
is also the least healthy based in the
uk with an extra hot whole chicken
coming in at 1
299 calories however a whole chicken
actually isn't the most calorific thing
on the menu in the us this is the
nandoka's choice burger which is a
butterfly chicken breast and coleslaw in
between garlic bread buns dude a burger
with garlic bread for a bun that sounds
so good that is a genius idea send me
that one of these comes at 1003
calories it looks like the main culprit
here is the garlic bread bun on the u.s
menu the garlic bread is the most
calorific regular side and it's the
highest cholesterol side as well
i kind of want to try it
it's not what you would expect
it's not like us garlic bread
that's a little strange as the uk's most
calorific side is actually the perry
salted chips these come in at 519
calories whereas the garlic bread is
only 362. what are you guys doing to
your garlic bread
i think we're just making our garlic
bread tastier
it feels like you're trying to attack me
harry trying to attack the u.s
we don't like that
while the garlic bread may be high in
cholesterol it pales in comparison to
one item in that area which is the
chicken livers
one serving of these contain
978 milligrams of cholesterol
comfortably the highest thing on the
menu more than triple your daily
recommended amount uk nando's don't
disclose cholesterol content but they do
dislodge fat content the fattiest thing
on the menu is once again the whole
chicken one of these contains 54.4 grams
of fat which is around 69 of your daily
allowance
nice
try that nice
nice nice
nice
okay
unfortunately nanos doesn't dispose a
full ingredients list in the uk same
here all we get are allergens and the
allergen list doesn't contain anything
too alarming we reached out to nando's
for more information about the
ingredients they told us that all their
chicken meets or exceeds usda quality
standards and is never frozen they also
grow their own african bird's eye
chilies on farms across south africa for
an authentic peri-peri spice
one piece of information you can get
from the uk's faq page is that the
plant-based great imitator wrap might
not actually be as plant-based as it
seems the based and the tortilla wrap
used both contain shellac now sherlock
is also sometimes called confectioner's
glaze and it's a natural polymer that's
used to give things a waxy finish and to
trap in moisture but where does shellac
actually come from well it's actually
secreted by female lac beetles onto
trees in india and thailand this means
it's technically an animal product and
although it can be gathered without
harming the beetles this is hard to
achieve in practice not nice
it's worth pointing out one other faq
from the uk page which is that the uk
nando's have explicitly committed to
never using chlorinated chicken from
america chlorinated chicken's been in
the headlines a lot recently because
it's kind of become the face of
differing food standards between the uk
and the us it refers to the process of
giving slaughter chickens a chemical
wash before they're packaged and sent to
consumers
what do you guys have against our
chlorinated chicken
jake joking you're gonna see oh there's
so many things against our chlorine
chicken this is done to kill harmful
bacteria like salmonella even the
european union admits that it's unlikely
to pose any health risks to consumers
but campaigners say that it also allows
farmers to cover up lower production
standards throughout the chicken rearing
process the good news is that it's
estimated only 10 of us chicken actually
gets treated with chlorine so it's not a
guarantee that meanders chicken in the
us will have been through the process
but it's an interesting example of the
different food standards in the uk and
the us
chicken tastes pretty good over here so
it is what it is
here is everything you will only find on
the menu at uk nando's and here's
everything you can only find on the menu
at a u.s nando's let's start with some
chicken options here we've got the
sunset burger which is currently i
believe exclusive to delivery platforms
this is a soft roll and then it also
contains chicken thighs cheddar cheese
red pepper chutney mayo and lettuce next
up we've got chicken wing roulette now
what this is is 10 chicken wings of
varying spice levels the idea i guess is
that you order a plate of these for
yourself and your friends you all pick
one or two and the loser gets blasted
with some extra hot sauce now obviously
we have to try this ourselves so myself
and our camera person laura are gonna
give this a go and see who loses
now i think we are all right
okay that one looks yeah you're you're
going dangerous i'm going for like a
menacingly red one yes you are i'm going
for the less menacing looking one
hopefully it's a red herring of denis to
deceive you cheers
absolutely fine it was okay yeah it's
spicy it's not like blowing my head off
i feel like mine's maybe
hot but if that's extra hot though i'm
like very underwhelmed slightly climax i
think laura maybe just got like a medium
or a plain one because she was not faced
at all i think maybe i got like hot if
that was extra hot i'm very disappointed
all i say a little cocky there buddy so
i got myself a bottle of the nando's
peri-peri xx hot sauce and i too want to
try the spiciest level that they offer
okay that might have been too much
that's extra hot huh no i'm very strong
i like the flavor a lot on that but wait
um definitely manageable yeah i mean
like i love the flavor of all this stuff
this is not that hot
[Music]
now for those of you who think i got off
lightly and actually want to see me in
pain you're in luck because in the uk we
have an exclusive spice level that goes
above extra hot here we have three
chicken wings coated in vusa xx sauce
which is one level above extra hot on
the nando's periometer now these already
look hotter than anything that was in
the roulette box there's lots of chilli
flakes on them that are visible and it's
just that kind of like alarming red
color that if you see a snake that color
you're supposed to run away from
some sticks are friendly
grass snakes grass snakes are cool and
of course because i hate myself i'm
going to try one of these they didn't
give us gloves like they did in the
wingstop episode which i guess is a good
sign i'm not great with spice so let's
see how this goes
is that a slow burn
there's a really slow bam not really
getting much from this i'll be honest
maybe if i just rub my eyes i'm not
really getting it that's disappointing
i like to say i'm not good with spice
but i'm paddling that with ease nando's
come on it would have made for better
content if you made me cry guys so it's
about the same as what i got from there
y'all tried your really hot wings right
well i just wanted a taste of the
the hot sauce that they provided us with
here if i can get it open at
any point in my life
nando's peri-peri sauce hot gluten free
excuse me
committing
[Laughter]
i should get an oscar
it was a little hot
but it wasn't like too hot that i'm
dying it's kind of spicy but this
already has i did that to trick you
did you see how it became a double agent
wow
i actually did have a reaction no it's
really sweet it just hits you in the
throat it's like on the other end of the
heat scale from vusa we have one more
exclusive based which is the peritema
this is described as mild and sweet and
is just for people who don't really like
spice and then finally we have something
that isn't technically chicken but more
of a chicken replacement this is the
great imitator wrap it contains
imitation chicken made from pea protein
so we have some exclusive chicken items
of our own harry we can get these
chicken size skewers which come with red
pepper and onions and they look
salivating
we can also get these chicken livers
which you won't currently find on the uk
menu due to the pandemic the thigh and
mighty sandwich then we can get a
chicken caesar in the form of a wrap or
a pita bread also got a lot of salad
bowls and that you won't find in the uk
there's a peri-peri chicken tender bowl
an ancient grains
bowl a chicken caesar salad a tomato and
halloumi salad and chicken and avocado
and pepper roasted bowl and a
cauliflower
butternut and halloumi salad
it's just like a lot of salad that's not
my cup of tea
this is my cup of tea
we have two exclusive appetizers in the
uk firstly we have halloumi sticks with
a chili jam dip and then we have some
sweet potato wedges which are served
with a garlic perrines i do not like
sweet potato i wish people would stop
serving on menus it is always worse than
chips and always costs more so we only
get the one exclusive appetizer the
garlic sticks on the side of your meal
in the uk we have a few exclusive sides
such as corn on the cob
some long stem broccoli spicy rice and
finally we have some coleslaw our
exclusive sides are a caesar side salad
portuguese rice winter roasted veggies
butternut squash
and corn in braised brussels sprouts now
in addition to the vusa sauce we also
have garlic perennials as i mentioned
which comes with the sweet potato wedges
and we have this one which is a perry
barbecue sauce the only exclusive sauce
we have is a coconut lemon perry perry
sauce it will take a while to go through
all of the exclusive drinks so we're
just going to show you some highlights
such as this this is a gingerella which
is an organic ginger ale nyx and kicks
sparkling cucumber mint drink with a
hint of cayenne and of course we have
this one which is a royal flush kombucha
now i personally like kombucha i know
it's a little bit divisive but it's
pretty good we can also get alcohol from
the uk nando's got some lager some
pilsner an ipa and a white wine
and bundaberg ginger beer
this honest iced tea
as well as a mexican coke which
throw me the bottle opener we also got
alcohol too
we got beer wine
we can get rose sangria
and spiked lemonade
nice and our only exclusive dessert
option is this barely baked brownie
let's finish out with the desserts in
the uk you can close out your meal with
a slice of chocolate cake which is
really good it's very moist with a slice
of white chocolate and raspberry
cheesecake and finally a gooey caramel
cheesecake i thought i'd have a crack at
explaining the whole cheeky nando's
phenomenon to our viewers from across
the pond if you were on the internet
like five or ten years ago you've
probably seen this phrase it just kind
of refers to this time where cheeky
nandos with the lads was just the go-to
activity it's like mostly teenage boys
would go into town for a day out wander
around the shops end up in nando's have
a meal and then usually instagram or
snapchat with the caption cheeky nando's
with the labs with this emoji
i'm going to make that my next instagram
caption cheeky nanders with the lads
clancy's my lad
come here clancy
she can handles with the lads
carrie you gotta bust a move more
yeah no thanks on that guys and no
thanks
that's quite enough of that
chicken wings they're my favorite thing
and i love to sing all right another
food wars episode where i did almost
nothing
i could get used to this
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between tgi fridays in the uk and the us
this is food wars
[Music]
let's start with the starters now tgi
fridays in the uk and the us both have
lots of starter options so what we're
going to do is pick the most popular
ones and compare those first up we have
the mozzarella sticks an order of these
in the uk contains four sticks
in the u.s our tgi friday's mozzarella
sticks come in an order of six six
sticks or you can get the platter which
doubles that
12 sticks we're gonna weigh three uk
mozzarella sticks to try and find the
average weight
hey harry is that three sticks
i thought we uh thought that order had
four
so three mozzarella sticks in the uk
weighed 95 grams that means that each
individual mozzarella stick weighed an
average of 31.6 grams
yes
so six sticks is 260 grams so that's
roughly 43 point repeating three grams
per stick now pro tip weigh your food
[Music]
then try one
[Music]
cheese fries is running running the
mozzarella cheese stick game the run in
the mod stick game
the uk does have loaded potato skins but
they're not currently serving them gtv
pandemic because they don't travel very
well for delivery however we were able
to find some in the store when they are
available in the restaurants they come
in serving sizes of 6 or 12.
well we didn't have that problem in the
u.s or maybe we just don't care either
way loaded potato skins are totally
available at the ustj fridays and they
come in two sizes you can get them eight
or you get the platy boy which is 12.
chicken wings in the uk come in two
portion sizes
as a single portion of three wings
or as a sharing portion
which is six wings
hey harry when i said to compare the
wings between the us and the uk i meant
these wings maybe it's cultural
differences or maybe i just read the
menu wrong
anyway
in the u.s our wings come in an order of
10 or you can get a platter of either 30
or 50 wings hell yeah dude i want to eat
every single one of these wings
if you like your chicken off the bone
you can also get boneless wings at tgi
fridays in both the uk and the us here
they come in two portion sizes as a
single which is seven ounces or as a
sharing size which is 14 ounces
in the u.s our tgi fridays offer
boneless wings by ounces you can get 10
ounces 40 ounces or a platter of 80
ounces
look at this you have no idea how good
this smells
that's so good
how is it so good
the ribs in the uk come in two sizes as
a half rack or as a full rack and both
come in either a legendary or a barbecue
place
our ribs in the u.s also come in a half
slab or a full slab
we're gonna weigh a large portion to see
who out of me or joe has the biggest
rack
[Music]
so a large rack of ribs in the uk came
to around
a bunch 366
children over there
joe's rack grow up
all right here we go
this guy's already falling apart
tender and a full slab in the u.s is
almost 600 grams how do you like that i
got the bigger rack
most meals in the uk come with a side of
fries by default so we're going to weigh
a regular portion of fries to see what
it comes to
yikes ours is only 120 120 for a side of
fries in the u.s
here is everything you will only find on
the menu at a uk tgi fridays and this is
everything you can get in the u.s and
not the uk and at tgi fridays let's
start with some appetizers for example
over here we have these which are
lightly spiced shrimp they're just
shrimp which are breaded fried and i
presume lightly spiced it's slightly
strange that they've been referred to as
shrimp on the menu here as it's more
common in the uk to refer to them as
prawns it seems like tj friday's uk have
cited their american overlords which is
disappointing
then we have two garlic bread options
this is a garlic ciabatta and then this
one is a garlic ciabatta with cheese
pot stickers
these things are so good dude
they're in no way authentic to what a
pot sticker should be
but in a category all of its own
does it pretty good the spinach and
artichoke dip this is like classic two
jet fridays right you know we got in the
us you know one guy in the uk
wing roulette
so what that means is you can get i
think what looks like nine or ten wings
at three different sauces but you can't
tell maybe get really spicy one maybe
get a mild one you don't know do you
want to play wing wing roulette with me
connor sure there you can check with the
paper but wait until i get mine
okay all right buddy ready
wing roulette one two three
i think i might get the spicy one
oh
yeah i think i got the atomic one
yeah dude that's fun isn't that fun
[Music]
it's fun to torture your friends when
you're out eating we have two exclusive
chicken sandwich options for example
this one which is the californian
chicken club sandwich and then this one
over here which is the louisiana hot
mess sandwich next up we've got some hot
dogs this is the classic american hot
dog there's really not that much to say
about it because it is just a hot dog on
a bun although joe will be excited to
learn that it's not sliced in half a
burger with cheese fries on it look
look at this thing i gotta know i have
to know
oh yeah there's bacon on too
this was this is good dude
i i would get this at tj fridays i'm
surprised how good this is so we got a
signature whiskey glaze flat iron steak
but that's the glaze sauce right there
and then we got the new york strip the
dragon glazed salmon you got a shot of
this before you know what i noticed i
mean they have this sizzling chicken and
cheese dish so i'm assuming
it goes through like goes to dining room
sizzling on the plate because i noticed
tjfridays does not have fajitas i'm
surprised by that so if you're ustj
fridays has fajitas let me know because
i didn't see them in our menu and i
didn't see them on several other menus
um this is the philly cheesesteak burger
i don't know
oh man this thing's super messy
they got the peppers the onions the
melted cheese
and
what appears to be shredded
beef
and all on top of a burger
no thanks
we have three sides which it looks like
you guys can't get in america we'll
start with these ones from the back
which are the cajun spiced onion rings
while you guys can get onion rings i
thought it was worth pointing out that
these ones are cajun spiced and they're
the only ones available on the uk menu
next up we've got corn on the cob
which comes served with butter and what
looks to be even more cajun seasoning
and then once again we have what is fast
becoming my arch nemesis on this show
which is the sweet potato fry those of
you who've watched episodes before will
probably know that i'm not the biggest
fan of sweet potato fries for this
reason they go super soggy they are
bland
they are not as good as regular fries
and they cost more stop ordering them
broccoli and cheddar soup
yo that's oh man
that's been sitting for a while that
broccoli odor just hit me
cheddar mac and cheese a classic side
then there's also a kids menu hot dog
which is smaller in size but also gives
you the option to add cheese which
personally not convinced is the best
move but you do you
some for the kids
get sliders and fries mac and cheese
what youngster doesn't like mac and
cheese come on now
and
pasta one with the marinara and it comes
with a side of either fries or probably
some veggies of fruit i don't know we
also have milkshakes at tgi fridays in
the uk we got two here which are the
oreo shake and the chocolate shake
fridays is known for their signature
drinks they're signature margs so you
can get a tj fridays in the u.s at least
your marks to go in a single
beverage
or
64 fluid ounces
of friday's margarita hell yeah dude you
know i'm drinking all this tonight
thank you varieties
now the one dessert option we were
actually able to pick up today was this
the chocolate fudge fixation cake
it's a very indulgent looking chocolate
cake with some chocolate icing and also
what looks like a healthy layer of fudge
in the middle you can get this really
fun slice of rainbow cake from i think
it's carlo's bakery rainbow cake look at
that now fun
that's fun cinnabon
caramel pecan slice of cheesecake dude
this i bet is amazing and i gotta give
it up to tgi fridays they were nice
enough that each slice of cake comes
with a scoop of ice cream
it's been a minute
so imagine a scoop of ice cream with
sprinkles in this sorry guys
we don't have a freezer now usually we'd
have a lot more to show you but because
of the pandemic tji fridays in the uk
have reduced their operations so here's
what you would normally be able to find
on top of what we've already shown you
avocado hummus cheesy nachos a ribeye
steak a texan steak garlic chicken king
prawn linguini teriyaki salmon fajitas a
warrior burger with mozzarella sticks in
the burger loaded warrior fries loaded
mario fries roasty potato fries a
s'mores sundae a cookie dough sundae a
new york cheesecake fresh fruit and
orange sorbet sundae and then on the
kids menu you can get fish fingers
chicken burgers bonus bites tomato tubes
chicken wrap vegan meatball penne veggie
burgers create your own dessert chili
billy ice lolly and a fruit cup
[Music]
unfortunately tgi fridays in the uk
doesn't disclose its nutritional
information we were able to find some of
it but that was through third-party
websites and articles for example in the
uk we found that one mozzarella stick
contains 110 calories 6 grams of fat 7
grams of carbs and 4 grams of protein
bringing the total for a side order of
mozzarella sticks to 440 calories
we did get our nutrition information
from tj fridays and a u.s order of
mozzarella sticks are 840 calories 52
grams of fat 24 of those are saturated
fat 1400 milligrams of sodium and 54
grams of carbs divide all that by six
and one stick is a hundred and forty
calories while currently the only
available potato skins are the ones you
can find at a store in the uk if we
could get them in the restaurant one of
them is 210 calories bringing an order
of six to 1260 calories
and in the us an order of load of potato
skins is 1510 calories that is 73 grams
of fat 23 grams of saturated fat
1950 milligrams of sodium and 176
grams of carbs that means that just one
skid is 188.75
calories a standard chicken wing of the
uk tj fridays is tossed in frank's red
hot sauce and contains 50 calories 3.3
grams of fat 0.6 grams of carbs and 300
milligrams of sodium bringing a total of
six wings because who's ordering the
three to 300 calories i don't even like
frank's red hot sauce why do people like
i'm sorry it's just bad
way too vinegary acidic i don't want
that from hot sauce i want heat
a standard order of wings at tgi fridays
in the u.s is tossed in frank's red hot
and is
640 calories 39 grams of fat 11 grams of
saturated fat 2
60 milligrams of sodium three grams of
carbs and if you break that down on
average it is 64 calories per wing if
you decide to get your wings with the
whiskey glaze like i got right here that
brings the total calories up to
830. now you have 40 grams of fat 11
grams of saturated fat 1 300 milligrams
of sodium and 51 grams of carbs now if
you're thinking to yourself i want more
calories
you're in luck just go ahead and get the
garlic parmesan wings that brings the
whole thing up to 960 calories that's 71
grams of fat 17 grams of saturated fat
1650 milligrams of sodium and 116 grams
of carbs hate bones you say scared of
skeletons well if you get boneless wings
instead you are now getting 770 calories
that's 42 grams of fat 7 grams of
saturated fat 4 100 milligrams of sodium
and 54 grams of carbs but joe i need
more calories i'm on this cleanse in
which i only eat calories what on earth
can i get you ask glad you did whiskey
glaze that kicks up your calories in
960. 43 grams of fat 7 grams of
saturated fat 2740 milligrams of sodium
103
car
bows
i haven't talked for a while now there
are two ribs currently available in the
uk which is the classic ribs with the
legendary glaze made with jack daniels
or the bbq ribs i'd love to tell you
more but unfortunately as i said before
tgi fridays in the uk does not disclose
its nutritional information on their
website they instead have this cryptic
message we strive to accommodate all of
our guest's dietary needs and are more
than happy to substitute side dishes for
preferred alternatives you can get their
frozen barbecue ribs at iceland stores
in the uk and as a result we know that
there are
1103 calories in a box in the u.s a half
rack of signature whiskey glazed ribs
with coleslaw and fries is 1100 calories
51 grams of fat 15 grams of saturated
fat
2180 milligrams of sodium cheese is the
sodium guys and 129 grams of carbs and
if you decide to go with the full record
ribs that brings that whole meal up to
1630 calories that's 75 grams of fat 25
grams of saturated fat 2 940 milligrams
of sodium yo and
178 grams of carbs now while most of the
meals don't have nutritional information
offered it does say on the website that
they offer the nutritional info for the
kids meals so we're going to see if that
is the case
so it turns out that's a lie and they
currently do not have the information
just allergens instead
due to the limited information available
online and also the reduced menu because
of the pandemic we're not sure 100 what
the most calorific menu item is but
we're pretty sure that right now it's
this the whiskey glazed sesame chicken
strips according to the info we found
online a portion of these contains 1 840
calories which is 92 of your daily
allowance to burn off the calories in
this dish you'd need to walk for 371
minutes jog for 157 minutes or dance for
313 minutes so
i better get started
the most calorific thing in a tj fridays
in the us that's currently available due
to limited menu options is this the
chicken parm pasta
yo
i don't know about this man
i do not know about this i don't that's
not cheddar cheese is it what is that
this chicken parm pasta has 1 890
calories 107 grams of fat 43 grams of
saturated fat
4130 milligrams of sodium correct me if
i'm wrong but that is the most
sodium-rich thing we've talked about for
this video yes
i think so 4130 milligrams of sodium
that has to be a record
154 grams of carbs 22 grams of sugar and
74 grams of protein now
this believe it or not is not the most
calorific menu item at a tgi friday's in
the us that distinguished honor goes to
the chinese chicken wrap 3 570 calories
182 grams of fat 46 grams of saturated
fat
this can't be right 8
220 milligrams of sodium
365 grams of carbs and 83 grams of sugar
so that is twice your daily calories and
your daily fat that's three times your
daily sodium in just one wrap that is
incredible tgi fridays i salute you i
have to try this chicken
[Music]
i have a shocking announcement to make
which is that tj friday's in the uk also
doesn't disclose its ingredients
information
tgi fridays in the us also does not
disclose their ingredients
what do we do now
i'm going in on these wings
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between quiznos in the uk and the us
this is food wars
in the uk quizno sandwiches come in four
sizes firstly we have the kids size
which is four and a half inches then we
have a small sub which is six inches a
medium sub from uk quiznos is nine
inches or at least it should be before
we got hungry and ate it by mistake and
then finally we have a large sub which
is 12 inches or one foot long in the u.s
our quizno sandwiches come in four sizes
the sami a four inch an eight inch and a
twelve inch
and i wanna give business props for not
calling this like a sandwich taco or
something really obnoxious
also in the u.s at a quiz notes you can
get party platters of either 20 3-inch
sandwiches or 14 flatbreads cut in half
there are no fountain drinks at the
christmas in the uk instead we just have
cans and bottles which are 330
milliliters and 500 milliliters
respectively in the u.s at a quiznos you
can get drinks in three sizes either a
bottle which is 20 ounces the regular
also 20 ounces or the large which they
did not have
let's weigh a classic italian foot
footlong from a quiznos in the uk to see
what it comes to
so our scales could just about handle
that turns out that a footlong classic
italian from a uk quiz knows is 520
grams
in the us quiznos classic footlong
italian is
about like
460.
quiznos was one of the first chains to
toast their subs so now let's
arbitrarily compare the toastedness
between our bread and the uk bread
in our extremely precise comparison
metric it looks like the us maybe has
the edge when it comes to toastiness of
the bread the inside of this is
completely soggy and the outside just
very average
[Music]
here is everything you'll only find on
the menu at quiznos in the uk
and here are a lot
of the usa quiznos exclusive items let's
start with some sandwich options first
the first one is this one it's a vegan
pakora sandwich pakora is an indian food
which is made of chopped and spiced
onions and opening this i got a real hit
of some really nice flavors actually
it's actually really good
very flavorful next up we've got one
which i'm surprised wasn't on the us
menu which is a blt
you can also get peary prairie chicken
from uk quiznos peri-peri chicken is
just like a kind of chilli marinated
chicken which has a little bit of heat
to it another slightly surprising
exclusive in that i'm surprised you
don't have it in the u.s is the bbq
chicken they've given us a small sub but
it looks like they've written smell on
it so
for the meat lovers we have a barbecue
steak and pepperoni sub then we have a
classic british filling which is this
one ham cheese and pickle now when we
say pickle here we don't mean slices of
pickled cucumber what we mean is pickle
which is a brown vinegary condiment made
with various vegetables
oh no they actually do mean pickle
don't mean actual pickle next up we've
got the zesty steak sub i'm not exactly
sure what makes this zesty so i'm going
to try it and try and find out
i'd be lying if i said this was the
zestiest thing i've ever eaten there's
some kind of like salsa on the top which
i guess is supposed to be the zesty
component but
basically not much flavor coming from it
perhaps the meatiest option on the whole
menu is the three meat stack so it looks
as if the three meats are ham bacon and
beef but there's also some olives in
there some lettuce tomato and cheese and
then lastly we have a double cheese melt
this is basically just a grilled cheese
but in sub form
the chipotle turkey on wheats it looks
all right
the honey baking all this honey in this
dude a honey bacon club
yeah i can get down on that the
southwest chicken on the their
jalapeno bread
no no it kind of looks kind of rough in
there this veggie sandwich is packed
with veggies man veggie on wheat
all you health nuts out there the black
angus this one i don't know about this
one i think having black angus i guess
like shaved steak
with the spicy monterey
turkey club overflowing with turkey
clubbiness
next up we have toasties toasties are a
very popular lunch snack in the uk it's
what we call a grilled cheese so if you
go to the uk and ask for a toasty that's
what you get toasties at quiznos come in
the form of cheese ham and cheese and
tuna mayo
in the u.s you can get a quizno sandwich
in sami form and what that kind of looks
like is a i don't know if it's a pita
bread but it's kind of filtered over you
saw it earlier we go over the instant
replay of the sammy
that thing you can't get those in the uk
from my understanding and i don't know
if you can get every sandwich sammied
you can get the classic italian black
angus the lobster and the slow roasted
chicken i have to say like i thought it
was stupid but this actually like looks
more manageable if you want to try
something out it's been sitting for a
while but like looks a little bit like a
gordita next up we've got crispy chicken
fillers these are basically just breaded
and fried chicken tenders and they come
in portions of four six or eight
on the side in the uk you can get a
portion of crisscut fries these come as
small or large and they're just potato
that's cut into a crisscross pattern and
deep fried
our last hot side option is garlic bread
it looks like it's made with the same
bread that quiznos uses for most of
their subs in the uk however there's
some garlic butter spread on top of it
and then it's toasted as well you can
also get this with cheese
tater
in the u.s of a regular and jalapeno
bacon
yeah whoa
[Music]
i brought a bit right into a jalapeno
okay
slow down joe
pizza time pizza time in the uk quiznos
offers a range of pizzas we're gonna go
through them one by one to show you what
they are
let's start with this one now this one
is the chicken baja which is a barbecue
sauce based pizza with some bacon some
barbecue chicken some kind of baja sauce
i presume and some red onion as well our
next pizza option is the peri-peri
chicken this one's pretty straight
forward it's prepared chicken peppers
and onions
from there we're moving on to the veggie
supreme this is a vegetarian friendly
option with some peppers mushrooms
onions and olives
then we're moving on to the bbq chicken
pizza this one has a barbecue sauce base
some barbecue chicken and then once
again peppers and onions
i personally hate it when they use
barbecue sauce as the base instead of
tomato sauce like it ain't broke don't
fix it then finally we have the classics
margarita and pepperoni really not much
to say about
these christmas in the uk also offers a
range of wraps and salads the following
things can be used in either form
chicken caesar barbecue chicken and
ranch tuna honey mustard chicken perri
perry chicken and mediterranean salad
soups this was this chili
chili
ooh cheddar brownie i'm gonna open this
that's cheddar broccoli sorry dude
yeah oh it's not that this is a bad
version of the soup it's that cheddar
broccoli or cheese broccoli i mean this
smells exactly like a fart
and everyone's favorite chicken noodle
salads
uh you get a side garden salad
like the lops are supposed to be like a
thing for them so you can also get
lobster salad and that
actually looks pretty good uh this is
the uh i think the chef salad
uh the italian salad which i think is
everything that comes on the italian
sandwich
thrown in a bowl
and then finally we have some snack
options christmas in the uk offers these
real branded crisps which come as sea
salt or cheese and onion flavor we can
get a fruits and oat cookie from a uk
christmas
the packaging advertises this as a giant
cookie but to me this is just a regular
sized cookie so i don't know if all the
workers at paterson's are just very
small or if they need to change their
terminology
and finally we have two muffin options
chocolate or blueberry these fantastic
chips are available at quiznos in the us
uh miss vicki has a bunch of different
brands on top of that at quiznos you can
get so many other types of chips let's
get a few of those on the screen right
now
quiznos in the u.s we got your chips
covered
getting great audio as i cut us right in
front of a mic
unfortunately quizlet is in the uk
doesn't dispose any of its nutritional
information so i'm just going to sit
here and like think about pokemon i
guess
[Music]
what's pokemon
at quiznos in the us a classic italian
12 inch sub is 1260 calories 63 grams of
fat 22 grams of saturated fat 3 760
milligrams of sodium and 115 grams of
carbs if you're worried about sodium i
got some bad news
throw in a bag
of the lovely miss vicki's sea salt
chips
arguably the best flavor of miss vicki's
chips the sea salt it's like sea salt
and who cares love these chips and
a large coke
yes more that's a regular can we get
someone in post to make that bigger
thank you
add these two things and now your meal
is
2040 calories 84 grams of fat 25 of
those grams of saturated 4 290
milligrams of sodium and
264 grams of carbos for those of you
with the sweet tooth if you want to
substitute the chips for a cookie
for a cookie
[Music]
[Music]
for a cookie
now you got to cook instead of the chips
with the large coke still you're going
to go up to
2133 calories 81 grams of fat 33 grams
of a saturated fat
4 100 milligrams of sodium and
279 grams of carbs
is it as you or a juice
thank you
this life-saving device stops are you
kidding me this video is two seconds
long
great thanks guys
in the u.s a french dip 12 inch with
you
right is 1140 calories 45 grams of fat
14 saturated fat 3 370 milligrams of
sodium and 119 carbs now connor i gotta
get personal for a second here the last
time i ate at quiznos was probably 12
years ago i worked in an office job that
i really hated in the lobby was a
quiznos
and i went there one day with a
co-worker got a sandwich
and on the way out that co-worker said
to me what'd you think and i believe my
exact words were you'd have to pay me to
eat a quiz nose again 12 years later
they're paying me to eat a quiznos
dude
this is pretty good
this is not the most calorific sandwich
on a quizno's menu that distinguished
honor goes to the 12-inch italian
meatball it's 1300 390 calories for one
12-inch sandwich
this sandwich is pretty good this
dipping thing this don't work i don't
want this cold dip coming with my
sandwich when i get home and i want to
do all this in the quiznos and i
certainly can't do this in the car
quiznos listen to me i'm about to give
you a million dollar idea so check this
out you guys with some food science do
what the mcgriddle did
right with the syrup in their in their
pancake buns you do the same thing you
inject
this juice into the bread of the
sandwich so it's all in one that'd be
amazing dude i would totally get the
sandwich is this not a bad idea no
dipping right i just saved the brand
you're welcome i think i deserve a
quiznos black card now our american
audience might be wondering quiznos
didn't they go out of business and the
answer is not really and apparently they
might be making a comeback research on
the brand shows that between 2007 and
2017
quiznos went from 4 700 u.s locations to
fewer than 400 they had a fierce
competitor in subway jimmy john's and
several other small sandwich chains they
were hit hard by the great recession and
had to deal with several lawsuits from
many of their own franchisees
in 2014 quizlet's actually filed for
chapter 11 bankruptcy in the us but it
looks like some of their stores stuck
around according to a recent article we
found in qsr magazine which does read
awfully like a press release quiznos is
moving forward with new designs menu
items and drive-throughs so perhaps the
future is bright i hate to break it to
you all these sandwich places are almost
exactly the same so there's no reason
why quiznos can't be just as popular as
any other ones right especially now like
doing like kind of a comeback what they
have to do pay attention quiz knows more
information coming your way what quiznos
has to do is go after each sandwich
chain individually and just position
themselves as not being that and picking
the thing that sucks about it just being
like hey we don't have that like you
want to beat subway quiznos yoga mat
material free in the bread there you go
give me another sandwich boys this is
easy go give me one yeah
dude correct me wrong but like jimmy
john's their whole thing was like they
make sandwiches super fast right in
order to do that it's like one person
slices the bread then the next person
cuts the meat right and let's put it as
a cheesebuy it's like five people touch
your sandwich to make it go faster
quiznos your sandwich won't be touched
by five stone teenagers
pot bellies nobody wants to eat in an
antique store
quiznos our furniture isn't 100 years
old what's left
jersey mike's quiznos we're not from new
jersey
from calorie council portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between pretzel monger in the uk and the
us this is food wars
[Music]
okay slight problem there's only one
pratt in la and it's at the airport and
due to the pandemic it's currently
closed the pret not the airport luckily
there's plenty of preps in new york city
where i have many colleagues and casual
acquaintances who would love to help me
out everyone meet irene hi everyone
sorry i'm not joe but i'll try not to
let you down i did ask if i could wear
one of these
but they said no so you're stuck with my
face sorry
here is everything you will only find on
the menu at the uk
and here's everything you can only find
on the menu at a us prep
we'll start with the drinks we have
quite a few exclusive drink options in
the uk starting with this one a turmeric
latte and also a matcha latte both of
which are made with coconut milk instead
of regular milk i'm going to try the
turmeric latte just because the color is
so vivid and a little bit off-putting i
want to find out if it tastes as bad as
it looks
oh man no
no it tastes like a chicken korma which
is great don't get me wrong but i don't
want to drink that from a coffee shop
then we have iced versions of both of
these next up we've got some frappes
then we have some bottled and canned
exclusive drinks as well for example
apple juice our exclusive drinks include
an organic single origin ethiopia coffee
salted caramel latte
salted caramel hot chocolate s'mores hot
chocolate
cold brew coffee
ice cream tea
classic lemonade raspberry lime
sparkling water
if you want to start your day off with a
prep breakfast here are some options
you'll find in the uk we'll start with
the classic which is porridge in the uk
you can get porridge three ways you can
get it plain like we have here you can
get it with a fruit compote on the top
or you can get it with cranberries and
seeds
very very croissant
at the front here we have a very berry
croissant which is a kind of like folded
croissant with some berry jam in the
middle at the back here we have a ham
bacon cheese and tomato croissant double
the pork double the fun then we have
some breakfast roll options such as this
one which is a sausage and egg roll then
we have three breakfast baguettes here
we have an egg and bacon baguette in the
middle we have an egg and salmon
baguette and then over here we have an
egg and avocado baguette on top of this
there's a couple of bits that we
couldn't get today because of a reduced
menu these include a veggie roll a five
berry bowl and a mango or banana
sunshine bowl which sounds just
delightful only exclusive breakfast item
we were able to get is the shakshuka
frittata but the other menu items are
the egg and bacon brioche roll an egg
and cheddar brioche roll an egg and
white greek frittata
a ham and spinach frittata
a morning glory muffin and an everything
bagel and an energy bagel we have two
exclusive salads in the uk this one is
the tuna nicoise and this one is the
chef's italian chicken
we have three exclusive salads the first
is the chicken avocado salad this is the
chicken seafood salad chipotle salad is
my favorite now we're on to sandwiches
and wraps we have quite a few exclusive
sandwiches and wraps in the uk we have a
personal favorite of mine which is a
smoked salmon and cream cheese sandwich
this one here is a jamun beer which is
just a very simple ham butter and pickle
sandwich then we have some baguette
options including this one which is an
avo olives and tom's baguette that's
avocado olives and tomatoes for the
uninitiated here we have a posh cheddar
and pickle sandwich two things to note
here one not sure why this is posh two
when we say pickle in this context we
don't mean gherkins we actually mean
pickle which is a british condiment made
with kind of like pickled juices but
also some other vegetables in there as
well the last baguette we were able to
get today is this one which is a chicken
caesar and bacon baguette then we have a
couple of wrap options such as this one
which is a hoisin duck salad wrap and
this one which is a hummus and chipotle
wrap the ones we were unable to get
today include a tuna and cucumber
sandwich and a brewed tomato and basil
baguette our sandwiches and wraps
include the cheddar and tomato chipotle
and chicken avocado wrap bang bang
chicken wrap
it's not spicy but has like a kick to it
this is good i might start getting it
the next ones we have up on our
exclusive list is the pesto chicken
flatbread this is the falafel and hummus
flatbread
pesto caprese baguette and the balsamic
chicken and mozzarella baguette
now usually i have a bunch of exclusive
soups to show you from uk prep however
they've reduced the menu because of the
pandemic here's what we'd normally be
able to find a chicken laksa a chicken
broccoli and brown rice chicken pot pie
soup miso soup pea and mint soup chicken
katsu curry soup mushroom risotto soup
and a red thai veg soup so our soup
options include the moroccan lentil
turkey chili and the tumeric chicken and
farro
faro fat i think it's farro they came
with all this bread though which is
pretty fun and it's like it's the good
kind of bread too you know bread is good
when it comes in like a triangular shape
that's just been my observation over the
years like oh that's good for cold soup
live from new york it's what shape is it
corner corner triangular
yeah irene i believe that's a rhombus
it's not a triangle triangle to my
understanding means three sides right
right joe you're a lot closer with
rhombus but i personally am going to go
with parallelogram
what shape is it is filmed in front of a
live studio audience i think this is a
triangular shape but i guess fine it's
like a diamond shape i'm just saying
that when bread comes in like
a geometric shape it's good bread the
fanciest restaurants i've gone to
they have bread that's shaped like this
or like even sharper
kind of bread are you eating that sharp
where are you going then finally run to
the snacks at a uk prep you will be able
to find some mature cheddar and red
onion crisps some smoked chipotle crisps
some sweet and salt popcorn these little
hazelnut truffles pretz a mango and a
chocolate brownie bar kettle corn what
even is kettle corn what if it what even
is kettle corn we are so exclusive we
were only able to get
one of our exclusive snacks which is
kettle corn so this was the only
exclusive snack we were able to get but
the other items on the menu are the nut
bar popcorn bar prep bar and some
omega-3 mix
let's start with the drinks in the uk
the majority of hot drinks only come in
one size which is 12 ounces
prep says this is to optimize efficiency
and to keep things simple for customers
however there are two exceptions to this
rule
firstly if you order a flat white from a
uk prep
it's served as an eight ounce drink
then if you order an espresso or a
macchiato it comes in one of these
adorable little four ounce cups alright
so in the u.s our hot coffees come in
three sizes
small
medium
and large it's ridiculous
but we also have some exceptions to the
rules
our flat white is only served as an
eight ounce drink but our macchiato is
four ounces like the uk's
and our expresso is actually just two
ounces i guess they're trying to limit
our caffeine intake maybe we're going to
measure our largest black coffee to find
out if you're actually getting as much
as you're told you are
so two preps credit that is exactly 12
ounces
we are not getting as much coffee as
they say we are but
maybe that's a good thing 20 is kind of
a lot not getting as much coffee as
advertised hi irene welcome to food wars
what about iced coffees well in the uk
these also just come in one size well
over here we can get ice black coffee as
either a 16 or
24 ounce serving
it's a lot of coffee
i don't get people who drink black
coffee
we're both going to measure our largest
ice black coffees to find out what they
come to
so once again this came to exactly 12
ounces
so the iced coffee is also
not the advertised amount it's supposed
to be 24 ounces but it looks like it's
only about 21. it's an international
coffee conspiracy
season two we're still dealing with this
i mean is someone gonna do something
about this
once again
maybe not a bad thing
it's like a lot of people are going to
disagree with that do you need this much
caffeine in your life
probably i don't know if joe or harry
drinks this much coffee i feel like joe
might he
he seems like he would he has that
energy joe just looks like he just
drinks like five cups of black coffee a
day and then he's like up at like two
a.m haunted
yes i do i drink a lot of coffee i
should say that it's only april and i've
already passed three kidney stones this
year what about some of the food options
this is an egg salad sandwich from a uk
prep we're gonna weigh this one to see
how much it comes to
it's exactly 250 grams maybe our eggs
are heavier
it's all those preservatives if you were
raised here you wouldn't be worried we
should probably be worried
it's not that good
but i'm hungry egg salad is gross
like it generally doesn't taste good but
i'm just taking bites of it so that was
a classic sandwich but what about a
baguette this is a ham and cheese
baguette from a uk prep so our uk ham
and cheese baguette came to exactly 200
grams well here's our famous ham and
cheese baguette
it says it should weigh 251 grams
it's exactly 251 grams that's impressive
it's actually kind of scary i know it
should weigh exactly the amount it says
it should but like it's kind of cool
when it actually does
next up we've got this muffin this is a
double berry muffin from a uk prep which
is a blueberry muffin with some extra
blueberry compote in the middle all
right so
we have our classic blueberry muffin
without the extra compo in the middle
let's find out how much it weighs
do you know the muffin man the muffin
man
yes i know the muffin man you listen to
elaine got a
can we get a can we get a hairy shrek
if we get uh harry's face turn into
shrek please you know i've never seen
shrek
my surname is an anagram of shrek
let's start with the nutritional
information for some of pretz coffees an
americano in the uk contains nothing
there's no calories fat sugar or salt in
here so that's also true here it's even
the same for our largest size 20 ounces
of us americano has basically no
nutritional value there are more notable
differences when milk gets involved take
the flat white for example in the uk one
of these is 80 calories okay well in the
u.s a flat white contains 90 calories
but it apparently has absolutely no fat
while the uk version has 2.9 grams of
fat so this is because pretz u.s website
bases the nutritionals for its coffees
on skim milk whereas the uk bases its
info on two percent milk if we add the
nutritional info for an eight ounce
serving of whole milk from a us pret the
flat white looks more like this
what about the least healthy drink on
the uk menu well it's actually this the
chocolate frappe one of these contains
439 calories which is a little over a
fifth of your daily allowance more
alarmingly this also contains your
entire daily allowance of sugar so
this is our least healthy drink it's a
salted caramel hot chocolate
pound per pound it actually has less
calories than the uk's chocolate frap
with only 410 calories compared to their
439 calories so while the uk strength is
limited to one size in the u.s we have a
second size option this brings the
calories up to 700 and also takes the
sugar up to 113 grams which is more than
double your daily recommended limit
why do they let us add so much sugar
and you can take it even further by
adding a syrup to your drink
one pump of pretz toasted marshmallow
syrup will add another 24 grams of sugar
to your drink bringing the total to 274
of your daily sugar allowance
oh god that's sweet
that's the thing i like
my coffee sweet like i only drink sweet
coffee so this is right up my lane like
it has to be so sweet it hurts me yeah
hot chocolate is what they call what you
want is a hot chocolate
you're right this is not coffee
it's good though
what about some food options in the uk
the most calorific sandwich is this one
the classic super club there is chicken
bacon tomato lettuce mayo and seasoning
in here and at least the total calories
are 526. that's lower than our most
calorific sandwich chicken and bacon
which is one of my favorites
one of these contains 570 calories and
also half of your daily sodium allowance
i did not know that
but this isn't the most calorific thing
on the menu
that would be the falafel and red
peppers wrap which we weren't able to
get but it has 630 calories which is
more than any other hot food item now
unusually for food wars the highest
calorie item in the uk is actually more
calorific than the biggest one in
america for us it's the swedish meatball
hot wrap which comes in at 661 calories
the calorie count might not be super
high for this but there is also 81 of
your daily saturated fat in here
for the most part prep uses natural
ingredients for things where possible
however after combing through their
ingredients lists in the uk and the us
we did find one or two things to look
out for for example caramel color it's
used in a range of prep products from
the dressing that they put on their
salad to the caramel syrups which they
put into their drinks well in the u.s
you'll find caramel color in the salted
caramel hot chocolate and the salted
caramel latte
which i drink
caramel color is worth pointing out
because it's on the state of
california's proposition 65 list of
chemicals which are known to the state
to cause cancer or reproductive toxicity
oh reproductive toxicity that's fun um
see i was scared but the good news is
there's only two types of caramel color
classes three and four that contain the
chemical that's the blame for this for
mel the bad news is that class four
caramel color does appear on the menu in
the uk while there is some evidence to
suggest that the amounts currently in
our food are pretty safe the state of
california banning it isn't a great look
meanwhile at a federal level the fda
still says that there is
no reason to believe that there are any
immediate or short-term health risks
presented by 4mel at the levels expected
in food
so
kind of up to you
they're lying we shouldn't be putting
this out there
the one other thing worth pointing out
is the difference between the wraps used
in the two countries there's only one
wrap used in the uk and it's this one a
kibbled rye wrap here's the ingredients
list
we also have kibbled rye wraps in the us
and the ingredients list is virtually
identical
but we can also get a plain tortilla
wrap as part of the falafel and red
peppers and pretz chicken part wraps the
ingredients list for this wrap is a
little more alarming there's three
different gums in here but it's actually
the femaric acid you may want to watch
out for it's an acidity regulator that's
pretty common in tortillas but the
european union says that while it's
practically non-toxic
long-term exposure is probably toxic to
your kidneys due to the results of
studies carried out on calves and rats
[Laughter]
yeah i would just not eat it
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between halal guys in the uk and the us
this is food wars
[Music]
in the uk you can get your order in
three portion sizes as a small platter
as a regular platter or as a sandwich
the halal guys in the u.s your order can
come in three sizes small regular
sandwich
we're gonna weigh a regular platter in
both countries to see whose is the
biggest
it's been so many episodes
why don't we just get bigger scales
bear with us one second
[Music]
first half is about
337 grams
three three seven plus three two one six
five
hey
quick maths
this thing we need to wash this thing
it's getting funky in here
here we go the regular
oh
640
640 grams it's a full meal
oh man this smells so good
fries in the uk only come in one portion
size this one in the u.s the halal guys
also only have one size fries oh this
case
do you think it's keeping crispy so get
soggy
very smart very innovative i want to eat
this so bad we're going to weigh it
first this could be another brick
hey
so a side of fries from the uk halal
guys came to 213 grams
wait
oh yeah okay
yeah
145 grams for one size of halal guys
fries
oh yeah
yo i've never gotten the fries these are
good
crispy don't sleep in the halal guys
fries
in the uk a side of hummus only comes in
one size and it's this one right here
in the us of a
hall guys hummus only comes in one size
and of course we are going to weigh it
so our side order from this came in at
246 grams i'm gonna eat all of this as
soon as the camera stopped rolling a
side order of baba ganoush in the uk
only comes in one size as well in the
u.s the baba ganoush at the halal guys
is also just one size in the uk you can
get a side of falafel and it comes as a
two-piece serving we did ask for some
but i think the guy forgot so we don't
have any to show you in the us the halal
guys you can get your falafel in three
sizes two pieces four pieces or six
pieces we can also get falafel
sandwiches
let's take some measurements
our falafel sandwich is eight inches in
diameter and for the moment you've all
been waiting for we're going to measure
the gaff with the tape measure but it's
really not fit to tusk
actually that's that's kind of worked
and our falafel sandwich has a girth of
let's say seven and a bit inches
from peta to peta
eight inches
yeah oh look at that
and it's eight inches
thick
eight and eight i like when things are
just precise like that
and finally it weighs
286 grams
and a falafel sandwich at the u.s halal
guys weighs
like exactly excuse me
exactly 250 grams in the uk if you want
dessert hello guys you can get baklava
it comes in a two-piece serving
of all guys in the u.s the baklava comes
in one size and this one piece this
piece right here
oops i ordered two i guess i'll just
have to eat one oh my god i'm eating
both of these
unfortunately hilar guys doesn't make
its nutritional information available
for its uk products we did find some in
the store and luckily i took a picture
from this we now know that the
sandwiches range anywhere from 419
calories to 694 calories and the
platters range anywhere from 471
calories to 1049 calories it's fairly
safe to assume that the 1049 calorie
platter is probably one of the meat ones
with all of the sides all the sauces
pretty much everything you can get 1049
calories will take you to just over half
of your normal daily allowance the combo
platter is said to be halal guy's most
popular menu item this is a regular
combo platter before any white or red
sauce has been added i would recommend
not eating it until it is added that's
just me our regular combo platter is
794 calories 23 grams of fat 10 grams of
saturated fat 1998
milligrams of sodium which i believe is
86 of your daily intake and also 96
grams of carbs of course we're adding
white and red sauces right okay the
white sauce pouch one of these is
roughly 330 calories 37 grams of fat 6
grams of saturated fat 420 milligrams of
sodium 420
and 2 grams of carbs
see this guy right here each package of
their hot sauce adds only 7 calories but
89 milligrams of sodium let's talk about
the red source now according to the
halal guys website their red source
ranges from between 100 000 to 130 000
on the scoville scale to put that in
perspective sriracha is somewhere around
2500 on the same scale and the infamous
hot ones de bomb sauce is around 135 000
so pretty close to this a lot of guys
have something called the hot sauce
challenge what it is is a small platter
with 20 lines of their hot sauce and you
got to be able to eat the whole thing
in 10 minutes with no assistance of any
beverages
not only during while you're eating it
but also five minutes after sorry what
are we doing
so one
two
there's times like this where you're
like i should have a will written just
in case
that's for
oh my god if i don't make it out of this
uh someone tell my cat that i love him
that's there's something in here
this is such a bad idea
all right
[Music]
oh my god
this stuff is really hot
oh man i'm like getting like a metallic
taste in my mouth like my mouth might be
bleeding
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
okay yep that's immediately spicy no
slow down here
oh god
this was a mistake
that's like really good dude
oh god
more
how long's it
minute now
okay
okay manage this
the eyes are watering the throat is
hurting
hmm
this is really hot
my tongue
back in the mouth everything
[Music]
no way i'm lasting five minutes i'm
breaking early oh god
i throw in the towel i can't do it
yeah holy sh
how long was that
three minutes and ten seconds
see now knows
that is spice if you emphasize something
is spicy
at least deliver and that's what a lot
of guys have done
people who build up tolerance
in their mouth for spice there's also
the talents for going out because
the worst thing about spicy food for me
is
the second worst is eating it
the first worst is
gonna be about five hours
speaking of which
it would have been smarter to do this
the end of the shoot
now
if you were to go with the falafel
sandwich in the u.s it would be 641
calories 26 grams of fat 4 grams of
saturated fat 1259 milligrams of sodium
and 82 grams of carbs
[Music]
currently hello guys don't provide that
much information when it comes to the
ingredients of their meats and rices
what we do know as you can imagine is
that halal guys food is indeed halal
certified the halal guy's chicken recipe
is a secret so we assume similar to
other middle eastern street meats it is
marinated in herbs lemon olive oil salt
and pepper i got all this info from the
halal guys legendary eat story we did
about a year ago so uh thank you to
those producers for doing my homework
the beef is also a secret recipe but
from what we know it's likely to be
flavored with things like salt pepper
oregano and paprika but the halal guys
can't be tight-lipped on their sauces
now that they are available for retail
so the hot sauce in the u.s and assuming
the uk ingredients are ground red pepper
vinegar salt
various spices question mark question
mark question mark and concentrated
lemon juice
uh white sauce soybean oil water egg
yolk distilled vinegar less than two
percent of salt sugar spices natural
flavors xanthan gum
sodium benzonates and calcium
disodium edta
or edta to maintain freshness
contains eggs
according to the white source packets it
contains
soybean oil water egg spirit vinegar
salt sugar pepper preservative potassium
sorbate thickener xanthan gum mustard
antioxidant calcium disodium edta and
natural flavouring
for the halal guys pita bread i had to
do some deep investigative journalism
specifically i called the halal guys in
downtown la and they told me that the
pitas that they use are these cantos
eurobread pre-oiled is this the pita
breads they use for all halal guys i
called and emailed kantos and they did
not get back to me guys what's the story
so i'm going to assume that they do so
this pita contains unbleached
unbrom
it no unbleached unbromated enriched
flour niacin b complex vitamin thiamine
b1 vitamin reduced iron riboflavin b2
vitamin folic acid water and soybean and
contains 2 or less of the following
ingredients calcium proponents a
preservative corn syrup solids
okay
pumeric acid guar gum salt sesame flour
sodium bicarbonate sorbic acid a
preservative soy flour sugar vegetable
mono and diglycerides vegetable
l-cysteine wheat enzymes whole wheat
flour and yeast
one thing to look out for there is the
fumaric acid that they use while this is
practically non-toxic because the
amounts in our food are very small the
european union does say that in high
doses this can be nephrotoxic which is
toxic to your kidneys so you might want
to go easy on the pitters one thing we
found out just by purchasing the product
is that the baklava in the uk actually
contains some questionable food
colorings the first is blue one also
known as brilliant blue this is kind of
hard to come by in the uk as it's just
fallen out of favor thanks to the
smarties controversy blue one used to be
the blue coloring used in smarties in
the uk however it was removed after
there was a panic about it potentially
causing hyperactivity in children it
famously took smarties years to come up
with a natural replacement for the blue
coloring they finally settled on
spirulina which is made from seaweed on
a not unrelated note there's also yellow
five in here also known as tetrazim
yellow 5 is one of the chemicals
highlighted by a 2007 study
investigating links between food
colorings and hyperactivity in children
the initial results did seem to show a
link between the two however since then
people have backtracked and said that
further study may be required despite
that foods containing these chemicals in
the european union must still bear a
warning that they may have an adverse
effect on attention in children we don't
see a warning on this box so hello guys
you might want to update your packaging
here is everything you will only find on
the menu at a uk hello guys and here are
the exclusives you can get in the usa
yeah believe it or not this is probably
our shortest exclusive section ever all
the things you can only find on the menu
in the uk are an orange fanta or a lemon
planter i'm assuming you guys do have
fanta in the us but for me uh obviously
phantom orange is the classic however
fancy lemon absolutely amazing for some
reason it's not super common in the uk
but if you go into mainland europe
particularly like slightly hotter places
like spain or greece this is kind of
everywhere so for me it just brings back
memories of like being on a beach bar
with my family sipping a fancy lemon
having a great time
so forgive me if i'm wrong i didn't see
this anywhere on the halal guys london
venues it is
16.9 fluid ounces of the white sauce
look how big this is this is hilarious
ugh cider olives
uh oh you can also get a side of
jalapenos
if the hot sauce wasn't hot enough
here you go
just get yourself a side of tahini
for desserts you can also get
a lot of guys cookies
that's pretty much it i'm going to lie
down because hot sauce is a terrible
invention cheers
from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between pringles in the uk and the us
this is food wars
in the uk our smallest pringle size is a
40 gram tube
these come as a single tube as a box of
12
or around the holidays we can get a
pringles christmas cracker which comes
with four 40 gram tubes in the us the
smallest portion of pringles you can get
is this a snack stack this 19 gram snack
stack comes in units of 12
18. this is super weird 27
and
48
snack
stacks
our next size is a 70 gram tube
we also have pringles in this grab and
go size which is 2.5 ounces or 71 grams
you can get them in single obviously or
in packs of 15. this isn't even the
biggest grab-and-go size apparently they
have a sizes even bigger that's 74 grams
or 2.5 ounces uh i ate that on the way
here i'm sorry and then from there we go
to a full-size tube which is 200 grams
all flavors wear the same amount in the
uk
in the us our regular tubes are actually
smaller you get about 5.5 ounces per
tube but the flavor actually adds to the
weight here's an original pringles and
this is only 5.2 ounces huh point three
point three more for the flavor
but the uk stops the regular not here in
the us check it out
the party tube
6.8 ounces of chip right there seeing as
the weights are so similar we're going
to count how many pringles are in a uk
regular tube versus the us party stack
tube to see who's getting more
all right let's do it
oh yeah
yeah definitely need a bigger tray i
might have to go into the table
this is going to be boring pringles they
don't break as easily
i have regularly eaten a whole tube of
pringles by myself
oh what
what where here
this one i'm gonna eat them all instead
of putting them back in the tube it's
taking all my willpower and that snack
on these as i'm doing it
[Music]
most people can't then swallow the whole
thing
most people aren't me
not most people are party stack holds
roughly 104
pringles so it looks like a regular tube
in the uk contains around 92 pringles
how many can i get in my mouth at once
as well that's what i don't know without
like crunching them all up and breaking
them i'm gonna see if i can do ten nine
ten pringles but i'm gonna go with
thirteen lucky thirteen
[Music]
off
[Music]
[Music]
i do not have the mouth for pringles
apparently my proverbial hat off to you
the crown is yours
this right here is roughly 100 grams of
original salted pringles chips in the
u.s it contains the following 535
calories 32.13 grams of fat
535.5 milligrams of sodium and
57.12 grams of carbs i know you can't
tell but this is like two-thirds of the
tube right and it contains almost half
of your fat allowance for the day 100
grams of original pringles in the uk
contains the following
514 calories 33 grams of fat 520
milligrams of sodium and 51 grams of
carbs that means our pringles have
slightly more fat than the us version
but almost half the saturated fat
in the u.s majority of the pringle
flavors have the same number of calories
as the original flavor but there are
some changes to some of the other
numbers when you branch out a saltier
sprinkle is actually the salt and
vinegar 100 grams of uk salt and vinegar
is 40 of your daily allowance of sodium
the saltiest of the pringles in the us
are the buffalo ranch 100 grams of them
contain 999
milligrams of sodium
avoid
avoid
what in the good god oh man
i can't believe the flavor in these
things i i gotta try that again
[Music]
oh my god
these are so disgusting this might be
the worst thing i've tasted on the show
all the salt for all the buffalo ranch
in the factory got condensed into one
container on accident and we bought it
this is so gross
[Music]
in the uk original pringles contain the
following
dehydrated potatoes vegetable oils
sunflower and corn rice flour wheat
starch corn flour emulsifier e471
maltodextrin salt yeast extract yeast
powder and color and natto original
pringles in the u.s contain dried
potatoes vegetable oil which is corn
cotton seed high oleic soybean oil and
or sunflower oil g-germinated yellow
corn flour corn starch rice flour
maltodextrin mono and diglycerides salt
and wheat starch these are actually very
similar the e471 in the uk is actually
the same as the mono and diglycerides
used in the us just used by a different
name the only other notable changes are
the yeast used in the uk the fact that
the uk colors its pringles with a neto
an orange red food coloring how much
different is the color
okay
the longest ingredient list for a
classic pringle flavor in the uk is
prawn cocktail it contains 28 main
ingredients likely with a lot more
because some of them aren't fully
disclosed like the flavorings and the
spices now
from what i can tell
the longest ingredients list for a
classic us flavor is the cheddar and
sour cream they contain 32 main
ingredients along with a bunch of sub
ingredients takes a total of 40. i'm not
reading this out loud on that list
you'll see of course a couple
ingredients that you won't find in the
uk pringles namely yellow number five
and yellow number six
i'm wearing yellow number seven it's
always with the yellow stuff these are
also referred to as tetrazine and sunset
yellow there were two chemicals
highlighted by a study back in 2007 into
links between hyperactivity and food
additives the initial results suggested
that there was indeed a link between
these chemicals and hyperactivity
however since then the european food
safety authority has backtracked and
said that might not be the case also in
that study was red 40 aka allura red
which appears in the ingredients list
for the memphis barbecue pringles and
these the pizza pringles foods using
these chemicals in the uk must still
bear a warning to say that they may have
an adverse effect on activity and
attention in children which means that
most manufacturers will just avoid using
them wait has he always been bald
yeah he's bald thought he had hair
no you're thinking of the guy from the
monopoly thing no wait look yeah hair
what the hell hair and no hair julius
pringle what's going on dude is this
weird this is weird right hair gates
2021 why does he have hair and someone
not in the other ones
here are all the pringles you find in
the uk but not the us these are most of
the us exclusive pringles cheddar and
sour cream jalapeno pizza honey mustard
which sounds weird
no
no
no
oh this tastes like a mistake someone
screwed up on those that might be the
worst one the buffalo was just too salty
but that is the worst flavor that i mean
this this stuff is
made for 13 year old gamers this is made
to sit and consume while you're stirring
a flashing screen
stimulus stimulus stimulus like i'm an m
of how
intense these are
hey joe can i try one of those pringles
[Music]
it's quite quite splintered didn't
survive the journey
i like that that's a good pringle
we need to get these over here
oh god
buffalo buffalo ranch yeah i'm not
eating these i'll skip those hey it's
the screamin dill pickle
what is going what is going on on this
label ship is wearing uh
goggles and a snorkel
it would've been better if the chip was
just like
you know when you go and get a burger
and the fries and they put that wedge of
pickle on the side
and the pickles touching some of the
fries and then those fries taste like
pickles this is a whole flavor of that
who wants that
over here we've got prawn cocktail now
this is really popular in the uk for
those who aren't familiar with prawn
cocktail there is no prawn in here what
this is is the sauce that you would
normally serve with a prawn cocktail
it's just a kind of like tangy tomatoey
pringle and personally i'm a big fan
then moving on to this one which is
paprika flavour in this menacing looking
black fiery can we have hot and spicy
pringles but they're basically just
pringles flavored with some jalapeno
extract along with some other peppers as
well
i don't smell too spicy
cheers
i'm getting like a little bit of garlic
a little bit of tomato not getting any
heat though people insist on calling
things hot and spicy
and then make things that really aren't
that hot and spicy next up we've got
smoky bacon pringles personally i love
these but i will say if you eat one they
stay on your breath for about two weeks
regardless of how many times you brush
your teeth then we've got some peri-peri
pringles now if you've seen the nanos
episode you'll know that as a country
the uk is obsessed with prairie prairie
chicken and pringles have capitalized on
that with some prairie chicken flavoured
pringles according to the uk pringles
website you should also be able to get
steak pringles and thai sweet chili
pringles but none of the supermarkets
that i visited actually had on me now
both the us and the uk you can get
spicier pringles in the u.s that are
called scorching how hot could this
possibly be scorching chili lime
not that hot
actually
yeah now instead of scorching our spicy
pringle range is actually called sizzlin
this isn't fun to say and it comes in a
kick and sour cream exclusive or as an
extra hot cheese and chili exclusive
which unfortunately we weren't able to
find today it's sizzle time this little
sour cream is a strange one because sour
cream is the thing you're supposed to
use to like
cool the heat down
definitely attack your tongue a bit more
than the hot and spicy ones did still
not like mind-blowingly hot also in the
us we got these wavy pringles which look
like they're just straight ripping off
ruffles classic salted applewood smoked
cheddar fire roasted jalapeno sweet and
spicy barbecue and something to do with
the video game hi-lo hilum is something
to do with the video game
halo
moa burger all this is for children this
is all for children we might not have
wavy pringles but we do have rice fusion
pringles these are pringles which are
made with rice and inspired by asian
flavors indian tandoori chicken masala
flavor and a japanese katsu curry flavor
we're supposed to also be able to get
malaysian red curry flavor a peking duck
and hoisin sauce flavor and a barbecue
teriyaki flavor the last exclusive
pringles i want to talk about are the
original lightly salted yeah
perfect this is how potato chips should
taste like
ah
yeah
unfortunately pringles lightly salted
equals normal everywhere else
it's so bizarre it's like hair and no
hair
why they made that choice
in calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between jollibee in the uk and the us
this is food
[Music]
in the uk jollibee serves their famous
chicken joy in six portion sizes
starting with
a one piece in the us you can get your
chicken joy in five different portions
a one piece with a side next up we've
got a two piece a two piece
also with the side we move to a three
piece a three piece that comes with a
side i'm so excited to try this is my
first ever taste of jollibee fried
chicken
now my first time harry
oh that's good that's really good i
don't know how it stayed so crispy the
next size is up our buck is a chicken
you can get a bucket in six
[Music]
or
a buck at a ten buckets from uk jollibee
come in three sizes starting with a six
piece
then from there we move up to an eight
piece bucket
and last but by no means least our
biggest portion size is a bucket of 12.
should have got a bigger plate
it's really good
[Music]
i just love chicken this is a good
example
there's little crispy bits that fall off
your chicken gold dust
let's each weigh our six piece buckets
to see if the chicken joint in one
country is bigger than the other it's
time for some jenga
ah
we have over 100 grams more chicken
i realize this is so arbitrary the size
of the meats
uh the amount of coding but it's nice to
win regardless
the chicken and jolly bee also comes in
the form of tenders in the uk these are
served in four portion sizes
as a single tender one one piece one
piece who's getting one chicken tender
has two tenders
there's a portion of three tenders
and finally
as a portion of four
one chicken tender i've never heard of
that anywhere well
here in america we have normal portion
sizes for our chicken tenders you get
them in three pieces
six pieces i think three is not enough
but okay
three pieces
six pieces
ten pieces
or
16.
yeah
tenders how do you like that
there's a little bit more going on now i
like it
a little bit of heat to it the batter
seems different it has more of like the
buttermilk flavor to it i believe the
coating
oh garlic man always
it needs ranch when you have garlic mass
who needs garlic mayo when you have
ranch
ranch is far superior to garlic mayo no
question
oh yeah love ranch
the worthy addition ranch is way better
herbs and spices
aren't they like basically the same
thing
then we're onto some jollibee
specialties now one iconic dish is this
one
this is the jolly spaghetti now this is
a dish made of spaghetti with some
cheese as well as a sweet style sauce
which is i think made with like banana
ketchup and some meat as well and then
it's topped with hot dog slices in the
uk this only comes as one portion size
it's a cute size you got there harry but
here in the us we have three sizes a
regular portion
our family portion
and the party portion look at this this
is supposed to be eight to ten people
it's like a lasagna look at that
now according to a friend of mine from
the philippines the pro move is to dunk
the chicken into the spaghetti sauce so
let's give that a try cheese like the
cold cheese
isn't doing any favors i'll be honest
okay yeah that's actually not bad it's a
bit misleading because their spaghetti
is actually the sauce is sweet very good
yeah together that's really good then
we're on to the burgers now jollibee is
famous for its yum burgers which is a
beef burger with its signature burger
sauce in the uk these come as either a
single or as a double over here in the
u.s you can get the classic yum burger
or this the double yum burger
don't want a bun for your burger you say
jollibee has you covered they have
something called the burger steaks
patties of burgers smothered in their
mushroom gravy you can get them in two
patties
three patties or the six patty family
pack over here the burger steaks only
come as a two-piece in the u.s you can
get a side of white rice we only have
one size and there's this one right here
same here our rice just comes in one
portion and it's wrapped up like this
very cute largest thing on a u.s jelly
jollibee menu is this the chicken joy
bucket treat d
as in
damn
i want to eat this all ten pieces of
chicken five sides and five of the peach
mango pies all of this for a reasonable
price of thirty dollars
this is the biggest thing on a uk
jollibee menu it's a 12 piece family
feast and with one of these you get a 12
piece bucket of chicken joy two sides of
fries two chicken burgers four chicken
tenders six dips and a 1.5 liter bottle
of a soda of your choosing
i actually want to start this section by
giving a shout out to jollibee their
nutritional information for the uk
wasn't publicly available when we were
looking but we asked them to share it
with us and they actually did so gold
star for you guys everyone else take
note the information is publicly
available in the us so no special
requests needed over here we now know
that an average three piece from a uk
jollibee assuming they give you a drum a
thigh and a breast would come to 1059
calories i'd be lying if i said this was
good for you the calories themselves
aren't too bad however there's just over
100 of your daily sodium allowance in
here as well as around 80 percent of
your daily fat a drum thigh and breasts
from a u.s jollibee comes to 920
calories so our chicken joy actually has
fewer calories than the uk equivalent as
well as less than half the sodium
content in both countries there are some
differences in the nutritional stats
between the different cuts of chicken
for example a chicken joint thigh is the
most calorific cut whereas the chicken
dried breast is the highest in sodium if
you're looking to cut back on calories
ask them to only give you drums three
drums in the u.s are around 660 calories
three thighs on the other hand will set
you back 1140
calories a 72 increase it's a similar
deal in the uk three drumsticks would
come to 777 calories whereas three
thighs would come to
1299 as a 67 increase okay what about
the most calorific thing in the entire
menu that'd be this the spaghetti party
pack one of these contains 5000 calories
as well as 10 000 milligrams of sodium
so therefore it is the most sodium-rific
thing in the history of food wars
congratulations this is designed to feed
eight to ten people yes but if there's
anyone out there who is eating one of
these on their own
listen to me
you gotta stop over in the uk the
highest calorie item would obviously be
the 12-piece bucket now depending on the
cuts of chicken you get the calories in
here could range anywhere from 3060 to
5196. even if they maxed out the
calories and gave you all thighs in here
it would still somehow contain less
sodium than the spaghetti party pack
unfortunately jollibee in the uk does
not disclose its ingredients the only
thing we were able to find was an
allergen chart it's pretty comprehensive
but there's nothing too shocking in
there the only thing that might surprise
you is there's lots of celery and
mustard use across the jollibee menu
same in the u.s the only ingredients
info we could find on this website is
that the mangoes and the peach mango
pies are made from real philippine
mangoes these mangoes are incredibly
sweet they're actually in the guinness
book of world records for said sweetness
plus i joavello give them the award for
fast food dessert excellence because
these pies are the best i love them so
much
these things are so good looking over
the u.s allergen list it appears that
the burgers at u.s jollibee have fish
allergens in them now i don't know if
that's something with the meat or the
sauces perhaps cross-contamination while
being prepared i have no idea
[Music]
here is everything you'll find on
jollibee's uk menu that you won't find
in the us
and here's everything at a u.s jollibee
you cannot get in the uk let's start
with some chicken now in the uk we have
an exclusive burger which is the
tropical chicken burger it's a chicken
burger which is served on a brioche bun
with cheese lettuce asian ginger chili
sauce and a ring of pineapple as well
our next chicken option is this one the
asian chicken rice ball it's a bowl with
some chopped up chicken tenders some
rice and an asian style slaw for our
chicken sandwiches we have the chicken
sandwich deluxe
generous of the mail
jollibee your chicken sandwich is
hovering around a
mcchicken level
love the mcchicken but i wouldn't send
the mick chicken into a war and
certainly i would not send the uh
jellybean chicken sandwich deluxe it's
good it's not fantastic what i bet is
awesome though
is the spicy chicken sandwich yeah look
at that they got that they got the
sriracha on there you see that in the
bun
oh and jalapenos there okay
this is actually very good
this might be i might send this guy into
battle
away from the chicken options we have
this which is the jolly hot dog
exclusive burgers we have the big yum
burger and a personal favorite the aloha
burger it's got pineapple you see that
and underneath
there ugh
bacon i love it i love this burger i
think a bite
it's a fantastic burger highly recommend
it exclusive side you can only get at
the u.s jollibee include mashed potatoes
i don't care
and the adobo rice
this thing is a brick of rice they are
generous with the rice man it's packed
in there the spices and a little bit of
like meat in here that's good yeah this
would be a good size it's a good call on
this side i like that a lot everyone's
favorite segment sauce talk sauce talk
we have four sauces that you won't find
in the us and they are as follows we
have a buffalo sauce sriracha mayo which
in my opinion is one of if not the best
condiment then we have a sweet chilli
sauce and finally we have an asian
ginger chili sauce creamy sriracha ranch
i'm very fascinated with this a
pineapple barbecue i've never tried the
asian ginger chili sauce before oh i
like it
yeah that's good awesome heat
whoa definitely hot you can see like
chili flakes kind of floating around in
there that's not a red herring pineapple
barbecue
pineapple barbecue
that's fantastic barbecue sauce this
tastes a lot like like a sweeter creamer
version of mcdonald's like standard
barbecue sauce
if they sold this in retail i would
absolutely buy it that's very good wow
i love you jolly babe okay
jollibee has a few breakfast offerings
in um
ginger chilli sauce powerful totally
fine jollibee in the uk has a few
breakfast options on offer we'll start
at this end with the breakfast burger
steak next up we've got the breakfast
chicken joy our third option is the
breakfast hot dog but instead of the
chicken or the burger you can just get a
hot dog on the side and the last
breakfast option is a breakfast young
burger we have one exclusive drink in
the uk jollibee and it's this the
pineapple juice the color on this is
like darker than what i'm used to for
pineapple juice
yeah just pineapple juice i like it a
u.s exclusive that i wanted to share
with you guys was the jollibee breakfast
but as you can see i don't have it
according to the jolly bee i went to
about a month or two before filming this
jollibee decided to start phasing out
the breakfast because no one was getting
it now i don't know if that's just the
ones in this area or nationally but for
the most part i think jollibee no longer
has breakfast so sorry guys and finally
we have two exclusive dessert options
here we have the mango coconut sundae as
well as a chocolate coconut sundae the
mango peach pies i cannot believe you
can't get these in the uk that is a
crime
this might be the best fast food dessert
yes really
this is so great
see it's like i'm on my third bite it's
already gone these pies are incredible
you have to have one of these pies
and this delicious refreshing
from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between snickers in the uk and the us
this is food wars
in the us our snickers come in seven
sizes the smallest one is something
called bites which i could not get my
hands on i looked on amazon they're way
too expensive i don't know why either if
i had snickers bites they'd be in share
size bags which is about 80.2 grams and
a grab-and-go bites bag which is
133.2 grams the next size up from that
are these the minis
look at this little guy
next size from that is the fun size the
halloween candy size
then from there we have the hundred
calorie bar
i mean
it's like a joke one bite
next size up from that is of course the
standard snickers bar
next size up is the share size of the
two bars
and the biggest size
this one
the slice and chair this is one pound or
roughly
453.6 grams
in the uk snickers bars come in a range
of sizes now candy bar sizes are a
controversial topic in the uk because
it's well known that they've been
shrinking in recent years due to that
there may be some slight discrepancies
between the sizes depending on where you
get your candy bars but we've tried to
be as comprehensive as possible we'll
start on this side with the smallest one
we can get which is a 20 gram 99 calorie
snickers bar from there we move up to a
snack size bar which is 35.5 grams then
we have a couple of forms of single bars
the first one being this one which comes
in a multi-pack and is 41.7 grams next
up is what we think is the standard
single bar which is this one which is 48
grams recently in the uk they've
introduced these creamy peanut butter
bars these are little bite-sized pieces
and each one is 18.25 grams these come
as a portion of three like this bar here
or as a bag of 10. the largest snickers
in the uk is this one the snickers duo
now this contains two 41.7 gram bars
leaving the total at 83.4 grams
[Music]
a u.s snickers bar has the following
milk chocolate which is made up of sugar
cocoa butter chocolate skim milk lactose
milk fat soy lecithin and artificial
flavors peanuts corn syrup sugar palm
oil skim milk lactose salt egg whites
and artificial flavors
in the uk a snickers bar contains the
following
sugar peanuts glucose syrup skimmed milk
powder cocoa butter cocoa mass sunflower
oil palm fat lactose and protein from
whey from milk whey powder from milk
milk fat emulsifier soy lecithin salt
coconut oil egg white powder natural
vanilla extract milk protein
milk chocolate contains milk solids 14
minimum and milk chocolate contains
vegetable fat in addition to cocoa
butter according to uk rules a product
must contain no less than 25 cocoa
solids to be considered milk chocolate
and in the us the rule is our milk
chocolate must contain no less than 10
of chocolate liqueur which is a roughly
equal mix of cocoa salads and cocoa
butter also it's worth pointing out for
snickers specifically you'll notice our
version contains corn syrup whereas the
uk snickers has glucose syrup what's the
difference well corn syrup can be a type
of glucose syrup but not all glucose
syrups are made from corn liquid glucose
can be derived from lots of different
fruits and vegetables like grapes
apricots cranberries jackfruits etc
according to the usda and on name alone
i'm gonna go ahead and assume that corn
syrup is only made from
corn
i realize that you're probably not
eating snickers to be healthy but
research has shown that many of the
detrimental effects associated with
added sugars are due to fructose rather
than glucose
[Music]
now people in the uk really turn their
noses up at us chocolate our chocolate
just tends to be way richer and smoother
and whenever i've had american chocolate
in the past i'm always left with like a
weird vomity aftertaste from it and i'm
not entirely sure why one potential
reason for the difference is that uk
chocolate tends to have a higher fat and
cocoa content it has been a while since
my last u.s chocolate experience i
picked some hershey's up from an
american store i'm gonna try it and see
if it's the same
this has like a weird glossiness to it
that i don't fully trust what have i got
on this
the texture's bad this is like grainy
definitely not as smooth as a uk
chocolate bar that i'm used to i'm not
getting quite so much of the vomit
aftertaste as i seem to remember which
is good i guess i'm taking uk chocolate
anyway i'm afraid so i was thinking
there's a hair on here i chew i've never
compared the two so i'm going to break
off a piece of the uk and the us
i mean just by virtue of like
the distribution of stuff it looks
different doesn't it
i don't know what uk vomit tastes like
but my vomit doesn't taste like that and
now for the first time that i'm aware of
i'm going to try a uk snickers
the chocolate is way smoother
way creamier
way more flavorful
and i don't know
how this is possible
but i g the the peanuts
are way nicer that's what i notice of
that bite and i have more peanuts or the
peanuts are more pronounced like it's
not even close man that was great
i thought it was going to be like yeah
no that is like a stark difference to
say the least that is a stark difference
and way better wow
[Music]
in the u.s a snickers bar this one
specifically has 250 calories 12 grams
of fat 4.5 grams of saturated fat 125
milligrams of sodium 32 grams of carbs
28 grams of sugar and 4 grams of protein
something to note a few years ago the
mars corporation did away with the
king-size candy bumps to cut portion
sizes to 250 calories or below but
this share size says it has two portions
of 220 calories right please this is the
serving size i don't know how many
people are actually getting this to
share but that pales in the comparison
of hungry people who are getting exactly
this one to eat okay that is a dirty
trick it's not 220 calories it's 440
calories the share size give me a break
in the uk a 48 gram stickers bar which
comes in slightly bigger at 1.69 ounces
nice
contains the following 245 calories 13.4
grams of fat 4.6 grams of saturated fat
88 milligrams of sodium 26.1 grams of
carbs of which 21.6 are sugar and 4.6
grams of protein the most calorific
snickers you can get in the us is the
snickers slice and share this is a
one pound snickers bar for sharing yeah
right and it's 2080 calories so i'm
going to quiz connor the cameraman right
now on here it says 130 calories but it
says per serving how many serving sizes
do you think this is
i think they'll put eight you think it's
eight double it sixteen 16.
they expect
16 people to
to split this
what
no
maybe maybe four
in the uk the most calorific snickers
bar is the duo bar now one of these if
you eat the whole thing will contain 426
calories
[Music]
here are all the snickers products
you'll find in the uk that you won't
find easily in the us
here's all the snickers varieties native
to the u.s you can't get really in the
uk unless they have access to the
internet
they're native to here we'll start with
this one which is actually a new product
in the uk as well it's a 99 calorie
snickers bar look at that
teeny tiny snickers bar i mean i guess
the point of these is if you're trying
to diet or lose weight but i feel like
having a small amount like this just
makes me want even more so i would
probably eat one of these and then go
back and finish off the rest of the box
which ends up being counter productive
then we're onto this one which
apparently you guys don't have in the us
as well which is the snickers duo not a
huge amount to say about this one it's
just the classic snickers bar but
obviously split into two smaller bars
then run through this one which is the
snickers crisp this is another new
product which i have not tried before so
i might dissect it to see what's going
on inside oh it's like two little bits
okay
okay
so it's like a snickers bar but instead
of the nougat base you get some rice
krispies
that's worse than the classic snickers
also how do you pronounce is it nougat
nougat versus nougat sound off in the
comments
i was surprised to learn that you guys
don't have fun size or bite size
snickers
maybe a good thing so we have the
snickers two to go bar and they have the
snickers duo bar
feels like it's the same thing now that
i look at it right can we confirm that
those are the same thing or that they're
different
peanut brownies
[Music]
no
not into that at all snickers almond
also i couldn't get my hands on it but
in the u.s you can also get a snickers
almond butter and a snickers maple
almond butter i don't know where those
are but i really want those okay so
they'll make it so sick
i'm gonna get so sick
[Music]
yeah if i had my choice i'd probably get
one of these instead of a regular
snickers i was able to get hold of a
couple of the u.s exclusives i got hold
of the crunchy peanut butter one and the
peanut brownie one now i love any
combination of peanut and chocolate so i
want to try the crunchy peanut butter
one to see how it compares to our creamy
peanut butter one peanut and chocolate
is just a goat combination
[Music]
i actually don't love that the texture
on the peanut butter is a bit weird bit
grainy let's try the creamy version in
the uk to see if that's any better
yeah okay this one's better the texture
is better the caramel has a bit more
firmness to it so you get a contrast
between that and the peanut butter the
peanut butter itself is less grainy and
awful and also it's just like slightly
less aggressively sweet than the u.s
version so
i think we win this round
as i said i also got hold of the peanut
brownie stick as well so let's give this
one a try
it's not bad i think my feedback for
this and also the crunchy one would be
to have more whole peanuts in there
because you know then you get the
texture contrast you get flavor no one's
going to complain with more filling
i mean
you have to be as curious as i am about
this
one big snickers
okay
this
proves my point what about this makes it
look like i mean it's not perforated
it's not in different sections i want to
point out this guy
comes in squares right so they possess
the technology to be able to break this
up for sharing but they're they're
expecting you to buy this
and
look it's just a giant snickers bar
and technically you're supposed to share
it but technically you can share any
candy bar if you have a knife but this
to me looks like there was no attempt
once is out of the package to imply that
you should be sharing this
from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between doritos in the uk and the us
this is food wars
in the uk doritos come in four portion
sizes starting with this one which is a
30 gram bag however these only come in
the form of multi-packs either as a
multi-pack of five or as a multi-pack of
12. the smallest bag of doritos you can
get in the u.s is the multi-pack size
which is this one ounce you can get
these in multi-packs of 10.
next up we have a grab bag which is 48
grams these are usually found as part of
like a lunchtime meal deal just as a
snack next size up a one and three
quarter size bag next size up this is
the two and three fourth ounce bag next
up we have our regular bag which in the
uk is 180 grams that's nothing our
standard bag size 9.75
ounces finally we have our biggest size
which is a share size bag coming in at
230 grams we got your beat again uk this
is our party pack 14.5
ounces which is also 411 grams 88 larger
than any size you have in the uk let's
count out all the doritos in our
respective largest bags to see what the
difference looks like the good news is
that i'm counting out this bag which is
230 grams joe is counting out a party
size bag of american ones which is 425
grams so he might be here a while sorry
joe yeah thanks
[Music]
we're doing the math so all you stoners
don't have to
fifteen times eight
eleven times ten
plus
one two three count out like ten chips
weigh em divide by ten and then go okay
that's how much a chip average weighs
and then weigh the pile of crumbs and
divide it by that number see how many
chips are does that make sense
could be here all day
so one chip
weighs
2.5 grams so the remainder of the crumbs
65 grams
with 65 divided by 2.5
so all together
168 chips
wow we're really smart i'm that was
those smart would you do that right
nine leaving our total at 119 doritos
my flatmates can eat these i won't tell
them the amount of fun fondling that's
gone on
here's everything that's in a cool
original dorito in the uk corn maze
vegetable oils sunflower and rapeseed
embellishment sodium five hydrogen
flavorings acidity regulators malic acid
sugar sodium acetate citric acid cheese
powder color anatomy enhancements
here's everything in a cool ranch dorito
in the u.s all right corn vegetable oil
which is corn canola and or sunflower
oil maltodextrin made from corn a lot of
corn in these chips cheese curds salt
salt tomatoes and powder extract
malic acid
there are a few things to watch out for
in here as well as in other doritos
flavors ah good old usa only food
coloring red 40 and yellow number five
it's done everything these days and the
uk of course opts to color its doritos
with things like a neto and paprika a
fun one to note that doritos in the uk
and the us both contain potassium
chloride now in normal doses this is
perfectly normal and safe to eat in food
as it's used to reduce the sodium
content in salt however it's also one of
the three drugs used in a three drug
cocktail of chemicals used for lethal
injections enough potassium chloride
will increase your blood's concentration
of potassium which will create an
irregular heartbeat and lead to cardiac
arrest uh how many doritos would take to
kill someone i think just one if you
crush it up put in a syringe and just
jam it right into the arm death by cool
ranch that's how i want to go i've eaten
five of these and i feel like i'm gonna
die
this here is 100 grams of cool ranch
doritos and in the u.s that contains
535 calories the total fat is
28.56 grams sodium
678.3 milligrams
it's a lot of sodium in that pile right
there we actually call those cool
original over here because no one in the
uk knows what ranchers but as far as
we're aware they are the same in the uk
100 grams of cool original doritos
contains 498 calories 25.5 grams of fat
592 milligrams of sodium and 58.1 grams
of carbs so our version has slightly
more calories fat and sodium than the uk
version what about the least healthy
flavor well in the uk flame grilled
steak is the highest in calories and
sodium four flame grilled steak grab
bags would be your entire daily
allowance of fat sodium and calories
with intense flavors full-on crunch and
a grilled steak kick doritos are the
great tasting bold snack for when you're
getting together with mates all of you
two assume i'm sharing these with my
friends
what about the least healthiest doritos
well the calorie count is pretty much
similar among all them if you're paying
attention to your sodium intake which i
guess you should be then i would say
steer clear of the spicy sweet chili
doritos a hundred grams of these
so roughly two of these is
963.9 milligrams of sodium that is a 42
increase from the cool ranch
everything tastes
like insanity i don't mind this but you
gotta like water them down or something
doritos this is way too strong
here are all the doritos you'll find in
the uk that you won't find in the u.s
and here are most of the doritos that
are native to the u.s let's start with
the classics in the uk you will find
guacamole flavour flame grilled steak
flavor lightly salted and hints of lime
doritos then we have a few which aren't
technically exclusives but have some
differences which i thought were worth
pointing out for example as i previously
mentioned we call these ones cool
original instead of cool ranch because
ranch just really isn't a popular
condiment in the uk there are also a
couple of color differences worth noting
for example the red ones in the uk are
actually chili heatwave whereas the
bright orange ones are tangy cheese in
the uk doritos also offers a range of
salsas and other dips like nacho cheese
and sour cream in the uk you are
actively encouraged by doritos and
society as a whole to dip your doritos
into these salsas as you can see on the
packaging here but apparently americans
find that super weird and will only ever
dip plain chips into salsa is that right
joe doritos and dips seems like
flavor mayhem the thought of dipping
nacho cheese doritos into nacho cheese i
think one bite would just unplug you
from the matrix that seems like
impossible to handle but yeah go for it
there it is
sweaty hands sweaty dorito hands save my
my pride
that's really on there i have no grip
strength oh wow
before you know i've loosened it up for
you
there we go
nice every episode
i need to work on my grip strength go
climbing to me it's just like that scene
in ratatouille where remy is feeding his
brother a piece of cheese and a piece of
strawberry and if you eat them one at a
time they're pretty good but if you mix
them together
it's a taste explosion delicious why
wouldn't you do this
you guys are missing out okay you're
missing out i don't think i'm missing
out i think that seems like way more
flavor that i can handle
personally enjoy so we got the tapatio
flavored doritos collab love to see it
this guy's salsa verde spicy nacho spicy
sweet chili shot a little bit earlier
this one the flamas let's look at the
fire on that these gotta be hot
oh
i don't like the look of this chip
yep yeah i would say that the flammas
flavor reminds me a lot of takis
but if that's not tacky enough for you
and this i think is actually really
irritating doritos also has something
called the
dynamatas what do those look like
takis doritos come on guys
let another company make some money
takis are better two other u.s
exclusives i could not get my hands on
by the filming of this episode is
blazing buffalo and ranch and popping
jalapeno
what appears to be i don't attempt to
making a healthier dorito if there's
such a thing so white cheddar and spicy
white cheddar it's simply our snacks are
made with ingredients you can feel good
about and come from the brands you love
we call it pure deliciousness
farf ingredients organic corn or organic
expeller pressed sunflower oil organic
cheddar cheese milk cheese culture salt
enzymes organic malted decks just put
the word organic in front of everything
organic maltodextrin made from corn sea
salt organic butter cream salt organic
skim milk organic spices citric acid
organic garlic powder so i think these
are more organic
you know they taste like sun chips i
hate sun chips we also have an exclusive
dorito shape which is doritos stacks
these are kind of like a dorito pringle
hybrid which are mostly just like
regular doritos but then stacked in a
triangular tube yo
doritos is going after takis now they're
going after pringles doritos let someone
else make a dollar in the space these
come in four flavors and we've got them
all here we've got a mexican chili salsa
stacks these flaming chicken wings
stacked some sour cream and onion stacks
and ultimate cheese stacks yeah i mean
they kind of
look like maybe thinner than normal
doritos i wonder why these are ultimate
cheese compared to just our normal tangy
cheese let's find out
it's not bad they're pretty good they're
pretty good that is an exclusive
container shape in the us we have an
exclusive chip shape and that is these
the 3d crunch two flavors that we got
are spicy ranch spicy ranch i think i'm
in trouble and
chili cheese nacho
i like it they're like
lighter fluffier
let me ask you guys a question
what shape does it look like
think really hard live from new york
it's what shape is it what does this
shape look like imagine if it didn't
close off at the bottom this looks
exactly like a bugle doritos is going
after everyone
that's why i like them so much because
there's a ghouls
from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between wendy's in the uk and the us
this is food wars
in the uk wendy's iconic frosties come
in three sizes junior regular and large
in the u.s we actually have four frosty
sizes junior small medium large
we're going to pour out the largest
frosty to see how big it is compared to
the us's
the classic hamburger at a wendy's is
called a dave's named after the founder
dave thomas ours come in singles doubles
and triples our burgers are the same in
the uk they also come as singles doubles
or triples now we're gonna weigh a us
triple
pretty close 14 ounces for our triple
now while the triple might be the
official limit on burger sizes at
wendy's wendy's enthusiasts have come up
with something called a meat cube this
is a secret menu item where you actually
take an extra meat patty and add it to
this so you get four patties which i
think adds up to around a pound joe i'm
officially challenging you to a meat
cube showdown the fastest person to eat
the entire meat cube wins you think you
got it i accept your challenge harry
let's do this three
and one start
[Music]
time
107. i wish i had more time to chew it
[Music]
need the sauce
need some moisture
the buns
how'd it do
dumb
[Music]
usa baby
ah terrible
i feel absolutely terrible
and yet
elated that i won well now we know why
the u.s has such an obesity problem
okay that's quite enough of that
back to our regularly scheduled
programming another iconic wendy's menu
item is the baconator in the uk these
just come in one size as a regular of
course in the us we also have the
baconator but we have a smaller
baconator known as the son of baconator
something incredibly unsettling about a
burger having a child that's also a
burger this baconator giving birth to
that baconator and of course we're gonna
weigh the regular baconators to see
whose is bigger
the highly regarded wendy's nuggets that
come in regular or spicy love the spicy
they come in units of four six and ten
nuggets in the uk only come in two
portion sizes four and eight
wendy's of course has fries and those
fries in the u.s come in four sizes
junior small medium large our fries also
come in four sizes value small medium
and large wear a large phrase to see
who's getting more
ours is way less
is that all about
another side that is probably unique to
wendy's i can't think of any other fast
food place that does this is wendy's
chili it has been on the menu since it
opened back in 1969. in the u.s you can
get your chili
for whatever reason in two sizes small
and large in the uk we only have one
size of chili which is this one we're
going to wear against the largest size
in the us to find the difference
finally let's compare drinks in the u.s
you can get three sizes of drink small
medium and large on the internet it does
not specify
how much fluid ounces are in any of
these
i've had to guess
too much way too much
way way too much in the uk drinks come
in three sizes small medium or large and
these are advertised as being 12 16 and
20 ounces respectively let's measure the
largest drinks to see which countries is
bigger
so a large drink actually came out as
close to 18 ounces than closer to 20. i
will say that in the uk you fill up your
own drink so maybe i just needed to fill
a bit more okay so their large is 18
ounces what is our small
20 ounces our small is bigger than their
large
man we love drinking our calories in
this country we love drinking our
calories
for this episode we thought it might be
fun to compare some prices from wendy's
in the uk and the us let's use this
baconator as a basis for comparison in
the u.s a baconator on its own no combo
would cost 7.39
the same burger in the uk will cost you
6 pounds 29 which at the time of
recording this was around 8.90 which is
a 20 increase however if you were to
turn this into a medium combo yes this
is the medium uh the price would go up
to
11.19 whereas in the uk adding a
baconator to a combo meal will only
increase the price for seven pounds and
nine pence so actually the u.s meal is
now eleven percent more expensive whoa
whoa whoa harry don't get ahead of
yourself wendy's in the us has an ace up
its sleeve the four for four promotion
do you get your choice of a junior bacon
cheeseburger a junior cheeseburger seen
here a double stack or a crispy chicken
sandwich along with junior fries four
nuggets and a value drink all this four
bucks
sadly wendy's has not replicated that
deal here in the uk not even in the form
of a four for four pounds deal if you
were to buy all the components of a us
four for four dollars here in the uk it
would cost you six pounds 36 which is
about nine dollars that's 125 percent
increase on the u.s price the real
damage here is done by the nuggets which
cost 2 pounds 99 on their own in the uk
that's around four dollars and 24 cents
aka more than the entire four for four
combo in the us so it looks like the us
provides more value if you're a little
smart about what you order and how you
order it
say you walk into a us wendy's you want
to get the baconator combo meal just how
unhealthy is it you ask well i will tell
you okay the burger 960 calories fries
360 calories and the drink medium right
coke okay it's gonna be 370 calories
this whole shebang
1690 calories that's 84 of your daily
allowance what about the same meal here
in the uk well our baconator is actually
more calorific because it comes in at
1010 calories however the fries are just
239 calories and the coke just 200
leaving the total at 1 49.
that's a 16 decrease from the us what
you ask is the most calorific thing on
the wendy's us menu it is this burger in
front of me the pretzel bacon pub triple
look at this thing
goodness
1520 calories 106 grams of fat 45 of
those grams are saturated that's
135 percent of your daily fat allowance
sadly that's the us exclusive and our
most calorific item is actually just the
dave's triple
in the uk one of these is 1204 calories
with 81 grams of fat of which 33 grams
are saturated
thankfully wendy's discloses a full
ingredients list for both the uk and the
us so let's take a closer look at some
of the menu items right now here is
everything that's in a wendy's baconator
in the uk drop in because this is a long
ingredient section premium bun wheat
flour water sugar yeast mayonnaise
rapeseed oil 78
water ketchup tomatoes 148 grams
american cheese slice cheese 70
milk beef patty 100 beef bacon sugar
table salt salt anti-caking agent sodium
ferrocyanide seems like a lot right well
guess what we got the uk beet again
here's everything in a u.s baconator
start with the premium bun enriched
flour which is wheat flour malted barley
flour niacin reduce iron
water
water
sodium
sodium nitrate
that's all of it
now that is a long list is there
anything in there you should be worried
about well we can start with sodium
nitrate which is found in the applewood
smoked bacon sodium nitrate is a
chemical used to cure meats and it gives
them that appealing pig color which is
perfect for bacon also super toxic it's
prohibited for sale on certain websites
like ebay because it's been used in
homicide attempts and a dental assistant
once died after eating just a one gram
tablet by mistake thankfully there's
none of that in the uk but just like the
us we do have lecithin in our american
cheese according to some academics there
are a worrisome number of scientific
studies which have suggested that it can
promote depression which is kind of the
last thing i need
outside of the baconator
there are one or two ingredients you
should watch out for in the pretzel
bacon pub burger the pretzel bun
contains potassium chlorine which in
normal food doses is fine but is one of
the three ingredients in the three drug
cocktail used for lethal injection
apparently enough of it would cause an
abnormal heartbeat and cardiac arrest
let's be honest if anything in this
burger is stopping your heart it's going
to be the cholesterol and saturated fat
long before the potassium chloride the
pickles also contain polysorbate 80. now
this is commonly used as an emulsifier
in some foods but with pickles it's used
as a solubilizer which means that it
helps other ingredients dissolve in the
brine
the bad news is studies have suggested
that it can cause colon cancer in mice
yikes
here's everything you find at a wendy's
in the uk that you won't find in the u.s
and here is everything you get a u.s
wendy's you can't get in the uk
this is ridiculous
let's start with the burgers now as far
as i can tell we only have three
exclusive burgers one of which i'm not
even sure is an exclusive burger which
is this one the cheeseburger deluxe the
reason i'm not sure if it's an exclusive
is because in the us you guys have
something called a junior cheeseburger
deluxe which looked very similar to this
and i just wanted to check if what you
guys considered junior we considered
deluxe over here yes harry they look
pretty similar the only difference i
could find is that ours has ketchup and
mayo and yours has sauce so i guess it
boils down to whatever your sauce is
next up we got this one which is the
veggie stack it's a vegetarian exclusive
there's definitely some like corn in
there
some kind of like black bean kidney bean
thing maybe some carrot and pepper
[Music]
it's not for me but i am a die-hard
carnivore so
maybe those vegetarians out there who
appreciate this a lot more our final
exclusive sandwich is this one the
avocado chicken club oh my goodness we
have so much to go through i guess i
will start with the
burgers um
here is something called the bourbon
bacon cheeseburger maybe a bourbon
barbecue sauce something for wendy's
burger aficionados the pretzel bacon pub
cheeseburger i think it comes in one two
or three stacks this is the three
stacker
okay the double stack
which is uh two patties cheese bacon a
junior hamburger junior hamburger how
small this is for the kids
junior cheeseburger deluxe oh yeah
lettuce onion tomato pickles
there it is
the big fake and classic
okay so they went to the chicken all
right chicken goodies the asiago ranch
chicken sandwich
okay this is the jalapeno popper
sandwich
but the pretzel bun bacon pub sandwich
crispy chicken blt sandwich looks to be
what a blt would be with the little
chicken guy in there
ugh so spicy nuggets mentioned before
and spices way better than regulars
then we have a couple of exclusive salad
options in the uk i'm usually pretty
suspicious of fast food salads but i've
got to say these actually do look pretty
good the first exclusive salad i wanted
to show you was the avocado veggie salad
however i think they got the order mixed
up and gave me an avocado chicken salad
instead so what i was supposed to get
was this salad which contains avocado
and then instead of the chicken and
bacon we're supposed to get some of the
veggie bites that mixed up in there
instead and then the second exclusive
salad is this one this is the apple
cranberry chicken salad you know it's a
good salad when they give you the
dressing and some other ekuemo on the
side instead of just jumbling it all up
and then like letting it get soggy we
got four salads then jalapeno popper
again the chicken the bacon jalapenos
cheese
taco salad wait so any
there's no ground beef on this there's
no meat on this it's like what you would
put on tacos at home shredded cheese
shredded lettuce cut up tomatoes next
salad apple pecan salad the summer
strawberry salad
oh
chicken bacon strawberries yeah okay we
have one other exclusive veggie option
which is this one
these are veggie bites now these are a
vegetarian alternative to wendy's
chicken nuggets just judging from kind
of the look and
smell of them i think they're made from
probably a very similar blend to the
veggie stack burger
and for that reason i probably won't try
and eat one it looks like falafel but it
just smells and feels way worse
i love falafel i don't love these
the pub fries
yes who hasn't been in a pub getting a
pint with the lads man they're really
pushing strawberries this summer wendy's
and the salad i got these two things
equals a lot to me i also gotta think of
apple slices
i don't know if this is a solo side i
don't know why we have apple slices if
you need something to dip your veggie
bites or anything else into then we have
a couple of exclusive source options as
well
sauce talk we'll start with this one
which is a garlic mayo and then our
other exclusive sauce is this one which
is a part of heinz sweet chili we love
sweet chilli sauce here in the uk i
don't know why but it's just offered by
like a lot of big fast food chains i got
a whole bag here
dipping sauces
buttermilk ranch
ooh
creamy sriracha
side of sauce um
something called the hot
chili seasoning we also have a few
exclusive breakfast items from uk
wendy's starting with this one which is
just an egg and cheese breakfast
sandwich i'm sure they would make you
one of these in the u.s if you asked but
it's actually a default menu item in the
uk whereas it didn't look like it was
one in the us then true to form for the
uk we have three different porridge
options for breakfast we have plain
porridge add some jam to it they give
you a little sachet of jam and you
squeeze that into your porridge and
finally probably the most exciting
porridge option which is this one is the
cranberry seed porridge there's a lot of
breakfast sandwiches to go through so
let's give it a shot i'll just go down
the line here maple bacon
chicken croissant sandwich everything's
square with wendy's
sausage egg and cheese biscuit oh
bacon egg and cheese biscuit
sausage biscuit yeah these are always
like
it's just it really is just the sausage
patty and a biscuit like can you think
of something drier to have in the
morning breakfast burrito this thing is
ice cold i'm sorry wendy's i did not
mean to misrepresent your breakfast
burrito i'm sure it's great this thing
it's like
geez louise
oh no i don't even know what this is
i don't know
chicken biscuit
biscuit and fried chick and nothing else
the wendy's the u.s you can get a cold
brew iced coffee a vanilla frosty chino
and a chocolate frostino now we have a
few exclusive drinks in the uk but
they're pretty much all hot drinks now
it looked like in the u.s you guys can
get the very basic kind of filter coffee
or you can get the frosty chinos and
stuff like that whereas in the uk we
have a full range of espresso drinks so
you can get things like lattes and
cappuccinos as well as some breakfast
teas
they have a bunch of lemonades this one
has an n on it is this the all-natural
lemonade it is wow and this lemonade is
really good strawberry lemonade is
excellent man wendy's with the
strawberries this year pineapple mango
oh yeah
tropical connor tropical i bet at the
tropical berry
good drinks
now also i'm looking for a flashin fruit
punch an iced tea and a sweet iced tea
and for desserts at wendy's and get
yourself an oatmeal bar
chocolate chunk cookie
and last and not least
sugar cookie
from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between ben and jerry's in the uk and
the us this is food wars
in the uk ben jerry's comes with a
standard tub size of 465 milliliters and
the coarse tubs are the same size
this little cute guy in the u.s we start
with these mini tubs they're 118
milliliters or four ounces a standard us
ben and jerry's pint is 16 ounces or 473
milliliters and also like in the uk our
cores this guy right here is the same
size as our regular pint our top tubs
are actually slightly smaller they are
15.2 fluid ounces or 450 milliliters
one thing to note is that despite the
two being very similar sizes the uk does
not refer to its tubs as pints that's
because pints are actually different in
the uk and the us here in the u.s we
measure our liquids using u.s customary
measurements which is based on an 18th
century english cell who cares all right
our pint is 16 fluid ounces in the uk we
use imperial measurements which were
only established in 1824 after the us
had declared independence our pints are
568 milliliters which is 1.2 times
larger than a us point to illustrate the
difference i've brought in an imperial
measurements measuring jug we're going
to fill it with ice cream
it just looks like the best milkshake
you've ever had honestly
according to target this is 16 fluid
ounces so we're going to put this in
here and see what happens and in case
you still don't believe us this is a
british pint glass we're going to fill
this with ice cream
while i've got this pint in front of me
it would be kind of rude not to try
wouldn't it cheers
[Music]
i found the walnuts it was going really
well then i hit a lump i'm down to about
here though pretty strong i think
it's the lumps that get you but honestly
not the worst way to eat bed and
cherries i mean as much as i can get
then i'm gonna start eating it
fun fact this is actually how ryan
gosling ended up gaining 60 pounds for a
movie role which he then got fired from
so it ended up being a little bit of a
waste of time but pretty effective way
to pile on mass now while the volume of
ice cream you get in the two countries
is theoretically pretty similar one
other thing we wanted to check was how
much topping you get mixed in with your
tub here's a pint of cookie dough in the
u.s we've let it melt so we're going to
strain it to see how many cookie dough
chunks are in a pint we'll do the same
over here let's go oh yeah that ice
cream is totally catching up with me
right now
i swear to god if i throw up the side of
this reminds me of the net used to catch
bugs in animal crossing
with the little
here we go
yes this is completely arbitrary here we
go
it doesn't look very appetizing when you
put it like that does it have to sift
through this i guess yeah there's not
one
two
just another day at the office really
isn't it twelve thirteen four fifteen so
in a uk tub of cookie dough we got
around 33 pieces of actual cookie dough
in varying sizes while we're going into
excruciating detail on the portion sizes
why not take a look at the cause tubs as
well
here's the same flavor in the u.s let's
cut this bad boy open
i can still eat this after i've sewn it
in half is there anything any chemicals
on here that are likely to
kill me we'll find out
[Music]
that core doesn't go all the way i mean
it's kind of like
chocolate vanilla
salted caramel
just stick it
i mean i didn't wash the sauce
woody oak flavor
there are all the ben jerry's items
you'll find in the uk that you won't
find in the u.s and here are most
actually half of the u.s exclusive ben
and jerry's flavors we'll start with
this one which is the birthday cake ice
cream i haven't actually tried this
before but apparently it's vanilla cake
batter ice cream with pink frosting
strawberry swirls and cake pieces
americone dream this is the stephen
colbert flavored ice cream i'm not quite
sure what steve tastes like but looks
like they got his essence in this pint
speaking of ice cream that is person
flavored the tonight dough do you see
that right there
there is
absolutely no way that's his hand
holding that gun good job on the
photoshop those guys the berry sweet
mascarpone another one you can only get
here in the u.s would be something i'll
be straight up with you as an italian
man about to say something very
controversial but this flavor went aside
i was like yuck no thank you where is it
it is literally the first one in front
of me ben and jerry's cannoli flavored i
mean marsh capone ice cream with fudge
covered the pastry shell pieces of
marscapone squirrels squirrels swirls
next up we've got this one which is
cookie dough switch up next up we've got
the doble chocolate cookie dough twist
caramel chocolate cheesecake this is a
no-brainer right here i bet this one's
pretty good what's in the u.s caramel
cheesecake ice cream with cheesecake
pieces chocolate cookie swirls hell yeah
dude this is going in the joe pile
cherry garcia they don't have
cherry garcia in the uk it doesn't seem
weird this is like when everyone found
out about ben and jerry's i feel like
cherry garcia was i have no idea if this
was before jerry garcia died or in
tribute of him chocolate peanut butter
split i'm gonna assume it's chocolate
and peanut butter what do you guys think
chocolate therapy chocolate ice cream
with chocolate cookies and swirls of
chocolate pudding like every consistency
of chocolate that's a chubby hubby i
thought this one's like super popular
chunky monkey was earlier it was banana
and walnuts and
it's the one i drank
it's not sitting right
next up we've got cone together which
i'm guessing is a come together fun did
the beatles do come together i really
i'm not a beatles guy i just listened to
owl city so i'm not the person to come
to for classic music advice cinnamon bun
tastes like cinnamon buns coffee coffee
buzz buzz buzz maybe this instead of
your morning coffee
coffee toffee bar crunch
everything but the dot dot dots
he has a lot of stuff in here give me
some more
glam fire trail mix go to cold room
another coffee one next up we've got
baked alaska now i've actually never
eaten a proper baked alaska but i
presume it tastes similar to this this
has got vanilla ice cream with
marshmallow swirls and white polar bears
then we go on to the caramel chuchu ice
cream new york baby super fudge chunk
salted caramel almond not as many punny
ones as i thought right vanilla caramel
fudge i wonder what's in it milk and
cookies
peanut butter half baked it was a
combination of the two most popular ones
that's pretty smart actually what this
is crazy this can't be right vanilla why
don't you have vanilla in the uk then
our last classic tub is so far so good
together i'm not sure why they needed
the together i feel like the pun works
better without them together ben and
jerry if you're listening fix this the
punch line
chilling on the roast truffles pistachio
pistachio oat of this swirl okay now
right now we're getting back on the puns
strawberry cheesecake
and this isn't even all of them in the
u.s you can also get flavors such as
boots on the moon brewed tomato
chocolate shake it cold brew caramel
latte ice cream sammy justice remix mint
chocolate cookie peanut butter world red
white and blueberry triple caramel chunk
urban bourbon pumpkin cheesecake totally
unbaked that's just the regular ones we
got a lot more to go through we also
have a few non-dairy and low calorie
exclusives in the uk we'll start at the
end with this one which is save us world
now then we have one more non-dairy
exclusive which is this one cookies on
cookie dough here in the us you can get
the in non-dairy form americone dream
and the tonight dough milk
and cookies cherry garcia chocolate
caramel cluster and mint chocolate
cookie uh caramel almond brittle creme
brulee cookie ooh the netflix and
chilled peanut butter have baked and
fish food a few other flavors you can
get in the u.s you can't get in the uk
non-dairy that i also couldn't get in
the u.s but i've assumed are available
somewhere in this country are the
caramel sutra core non-dairy the coconut
seven-layer bar non-dairy and the coffee
caramel fudge non-dairy then we're onto
some calorie options which ben jerry's
calls mufouria now this one up here is a
chocolate cookie dough low calorie
version but it's only 136 calories per
100 milliliters our next mufouria
exclusive flavor is the salted caramel
brownie one the next move fourier
exclusive we were able to get was this
one poppin popcorn the muforia light
flavors you can get in the u.s are
chocolate cookie enlightenment
enlightened mints mint
very good ben jerry's chocolate milk and
cookies mocha fudge brownie pb
marshmallow i'm slightly against the
concept of low calorie ice cream i feel
like with something like this you just
have to enjoy it as it was intended to
be enjoyed which is
the proper way if you're going to save
some calories maybe just save them
elsewhere and then treat yourself or
just eat less of one of these instead of
a whole top of that as you saw when i
hacked one open with a saw ben jerry's
also sells cause ice cream which is ice
cream flavors with a core of usually
some kind of caramel filling in the
middle we've only got one exclusive over
here which is this one the blondie
brownie core we got the course in the
u.s we got a bunch of course you can't
get in the uk the boom chocolata cookie
core chocolate chip cookie dough core
sweet like sugar cookie dough core week
and no bake cookie dough core brownie
batter core cookies and cream cheesecake
core peanut butter fudge core and salted
caramel core we got all eight of them
right here in the u.s we can also get
these exclusive topped pines now from
what i understand because i've never had
one the ice cream has a layer of topping
you used to be able to get these in the
uk but now you can't anymore whiskey biz
the pb over the top and the tiramisu but
you can also get a strawberry top and a
thick mint top
frozen yogurt
us ben and jerry's also has two frozen
yogurt options whereas the uk does not
have any sorry guys but we can get
frozen yogurt versions of cherry garcia
and half baked
all right in the u.s we got these mini
tubs you can get them in four flavors i
can only find one you get them in
american dream cherry garcia non-dairy
caramel chocolate chunk and non-dairy
pband cookies i've actually never had
cherry garcia
going to the palette
that's a pen right there baby similarly
to the top tubs we also used to be able
to get mini subs in the uk but
unfortunately they were recently
discontinued outside of tubs of ice
cream ben jerry's also has some no spoon
needed options in the uk this is an
exclusive one right here which is a
cookie dough piece pop we do not have
the no spoon options but we do have the
pint slices you can get them in the
forms of amazement
dream cherry garcia chocolate chip
cookie dough chocolate fudge brownie and
the tonight dough final no spoon kneaded
exclusive we have here in the uk is this
one which is salted caramel cookie dough
chunks cookie dough chunks we got them
too
and these are some of the exclusive
cookie dough chunk bags from ben and
jerry's you can get in the u.s you got
sugar cookie dough so i mentioned really
half baked six ounces for some reason
all the other ones are eight i don't
know why they did that the chocolate
chip cookie dough and peanut butter
chocolate chip cookie dough you can also
get the tanato cinnabundo gingerbread
cookie dough and a vegan chocolate chip
cookie dough one u.s exclusive ben
jerry's item that people i assure you i
tried i tried i tried to get my hands on
it in time of the shooting just couldn't
happen ben jerry also has two dog flavor
ice creams now they're not flavored like
dogs they're flavors for dogs the doggy
desserts is what they're calling them
and uh the two flavors are poochy's mix
and rosie's batch so unfortunately no
doggo wars this episode but here are the
pictures of paul and luda
here's a picture of ice cream
can someone in graphics make it look
like they're eating the ice cream
quick clarification before we start the
nutrition section ice cream is kind of
tricky to quantify because sometimes
it's referred to by weight and other
times by volume it is because the
containers are all the same size yes but
the density of ice cream can vary so
overall seems the fairest way to measure
is by weight in the uk ben jerry's
provides its nutritional information per
100 grams whereas in the us they do it
per serving size which is around 141 or
142 grams depending on which type of ice
cream you have so if we divide the us
serving by 1.41 or 1.42 we should get a
roughly equivalent figure got it let's
start with what is officially the most
popular ben and jerry's flavor in the
united states that is this the half
baked 100 grams of usa's half baked
contains 262 calories 13.4 grams of fat
7.8 of which are saturated fat 31.9
grams of carbs 25.5 grams of sugar and
90 milligrams of sodium 100 grams of uk
half bait contains the following 264
calories 13 grams of fat 8.1 grams of
which is saturated 32 grams of carbs of
which 27 grams are sugar and 84
milligrams of sodium so it looks like
the uk's is actually higher in saturated
fat carbs calories and sugar although
the us edges us on total fat and sodium
what is the most calorific flavor in the
us you ask turns out is the peanut
butter cup
i couldn't find it this magically
delicious peanut butter cup flavored ben
and jerry's ice cream that is somewhere
in this country 100 grams of it contains
the following 330 calories 23.3 grams of
fat 12.6 of those are saturated fat 25.3
grams of carbs 22.5 grams which are
sugar and 126 milligrams of sodium the
same ice cream in the uk contains 310
calories 21 grams of fat of which 12
grams is saturated 24 grams of carbs of
which 23 grams are sugar and 176
milligrams of sodium this time we edge
the ucan calories fat saturated fat and
carbs while they beat us on sugar and
sodium now these 100 gram figures don't
seem so bad but bear in mind that they
are for less than one serving
realistically i'm eating a whole tub of
this while cuddle up in my blankets
depressed watching netflix if you were
to eat a whole pint of the peanut butter
cup ice cream
don't the stats do not look good for you
two figures to watch out for would be
the 270 percent of your daily saturated
fat allowance and almost 200
of your daily sugar
here are the numbers for a full tub of
peanut butter cup in the uk keep in mind
that our tub is a tiny bit smaller than
the u.s one but overall we are still
better off than than in most of the
metrics
here is everything that's in a tub of
ben and jerry's half baked in the uk
cream
liquid sugar water condensed milk water
brown sugar
powder juice
seamless these are actually pretty much
identical lists so good job ben and
jerry there's also nothing in there
which you should be particularly
concerned about and this is kind of in
line with ben and jerry's overall
philosophy about sourcing ingredients
according to the ben jerry's website
they boast that their ice cream is
non-gmo fair trade and cage-free and
they do seem to live up to that all you
food wars heads watch in this episode
know that we always have to deal with
artificial flavors that are okay in the
us but not allowed in the european union
but the ones that ben and jerry use are
actually made with natural colors like
vegetable juice spirulina and turmeric
so while what's in the ice cream might
not be too interesting what's outside it
is actually worth pointing out in the
u.s the ben and jerry pints do come in a
cardboard tub that has polyurethane
plastic on both sides in the uk however
they've actually stopped coating the
outside of the tubs which makes them
more widely recyclable ben and jerry's
have said that it is their goal to
replicate this in the u.s at some point
this year which would save
000 pounds of plastic a year
from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between breakfast cereals in the uk and
the us this is food wars
hey everyone joe from food wars i'm
actually not in this episode because
myself connor and yuli are busy making a
new season of food wars with the new
country ooh but don't worry i'll chime
in every once in a while it'll be super
annoying we're doing a cereal episode
now obviously there are a lot of
breakfast cereals in the uk and the us
and we can't cover them all in one
episode so we're gonna start with the
two best sellers in america which are
frosted flakes and honey nut cheerios
then after that we might get into some
fun cereals which you can't find in one
country or the other that sound good to
you irene yeah sounds great harry
first things first frosted flakes what
is going on there in the uk we actually
just call them frosties okay this is the
one time i think the uk has a better
term for something because frosties is
actually kind of cute it's like besties
in the uk frosties come in five sizes
starting with this one which is a 25
gram box which comes as part of one of
these multi packs from there we move up
to a 375 gram box
next up we've got a 500 gram box of
frosties
from there we move up to a 750 gram box
then our largest size is this one the
big one kilogram box
in the us frosted flakes also come in
four sizes we start with the 60 gram cut
which you can just add milk directly
into and eat next up we have the
24 ounce or 680 gram family size box
from there we move up to a 34 ounce
mega size but this actually isn't the
largest one we actually go one step
further with a
39.5 ounce or 11 20 gram bag
that means our largest size is 12 larger
than the uk's in the uk the recommended
serving size for frosties is 30 grams
which means that our largest box
contains roughly 33 servings let's find
out what 30 grams of frosties actually
looks like digital scales we finally got
digital scales i leave for one episode
we get the digi scales what the heck
guys i want one
how precise can we go
not very
[Laughter]
that's
30.08 grams of frosties right now
in an actual cereal bowl that is nothing
in the u.s the recommended serving size
for frosted flakes is actually 37 grams
which is 23 percent more than in the uk
so while our largest packet size might
be a little bigger we're technically
getting fewer servings just 30 compared
to the uk's 33.
this
37. it did it
i feel like you know on tinder when guys
hold like a fish in their photo i feel
like that right now
now i'm going to be honest here that is
not a realistic serving size for a
strapping young lad such as myself what
i'm going to do is pour out what i would
consider to be a normal bowl and then
we'll weigh that to see what it comes to
so my actual realistic serving ended up
being almost exactly double the 30 grams
coming in at around 60 grams
57.5
okay this is 60.
if i was using a bowl i think this is
exactly what i would pour for myself
because i feel like what people do you
fill the entire bowl of cereal and then
you fill it up with milk but the thing i
for some reason do is i eat my cereal
out of a cup like a mug
i like that it's deeper so i'll put that
in and so i don't know what the
equivalent of that would be but yeah
cereal out of a mug it's like
it's fun
the first thing to point out here is
that i really gasolit myself and was
convinced that we had honey nut cheerios
in the uk however when i then looked
into it i found that instead they're
just honey cheerios and uh i'd imagine
the whole thing although our cameraman
charlie today was convinced of the same
thing so maybe there's just some
butterfly effect has gone on
honey churros in the uk come in six
portion sizes starting with this one
it's a 30 grand box and again it only
comes as part of a multi-pack
from there we go up to a 280 gram box
while i was looking for the portions i
found both a 370 gram box as well as a
375 gram box it looks like this one
maybe they are trying to use less
packaging but have taken that
opportunity to give you a few less
cheerios as well who knows
our next size is this one which is a 515
gram box
and then finally our largest cheerios
box is this one
which is
575 grams
panini cheerios in the us come in five
sizes we have the
1.8 ounce or 51 gram mini cup
the classic 10.8 ounce box
the 18.8 ounce family size
the 29.4 ounce mega size
and lastly a 32 ounce or 907 gram bag
that makes the largest u.s option 57
larger than the uk's
the recommended serving size for
cheerios in the uk is again 30 grams
that means that our largest box contains
around 19 servings in the us the
recommended serving size is one cup see
that's why you should eat it out of a
cup get it which should weigh around 37
grams that's a 23 increase on the uk and
the most servings you can get in a u.s
container would be around 24.5 which is
almost a 30 increase on the uk because
of course
but once again it seems like 30 grams is
just a really unrealistic serving size i
think again i'm eating much closer to 60
grams does that look about right to you
irene
yeah i agree with harry this is again
it's you need to fill the bowl so
apparently filling the bowl means 60
grams so no one's pouring out 37 grams
of cheerios this is i think this is how
much normal people are pouring out so
realistically you're only actually
getting nine and a half servings out of
the uk's largest box whereas we're
getting 15 servings from our largest bag
wow you guys are getting kind of ripped
off
unfortunately we don't have any
exclusive frosties in the uk here are
all the frosted flakes from the u.s that
you won't find in the uk we have the
chocolate frosted flakes frosted flakes
with marshmallows frosted flakes
cinnamon basketballs
honey nut frosted flakes frosted flakes
and fruit loops mashup this is limited
edition and the tiger paws jumbo snacks
i'll try one of the basketballs
tastes like cinnamon i don't think it's
that good
shaq
will put his face on literally anything
look at that smile he has on that face
right there that's that i'm getting paid
he's hanging out with tony the tiger
right he also does a commercial with the
general space jam should have been that
i should have been shaq with all the
cartoon characters of products that he
advertises with the shaq the general
tony the tiger
uh a can of arizona iced tea what else
was he doing that would have been a much
better movie this this is exciting this
is this is a fake novel just a real
novelty these are literally like lucky
charms i'm only eating the marshmallows
and you know it turned to milk like
purple or pink or like a weird ugly
color but it tastes so good
i'm sorry you can't have this harry
you know it's probably banned in the uk
because of the hormones or like
artificial products anyway
these are interesting
oh my god okay
this looks like the baby cereal like the
baby's neck or like the toddler snacks
they are it looks like the baby cereal
it's like
but it's like a little bit bigger very
exciting
it's not dry it's not as sweet i would
add more sugar to this
i'm like my dipping sugar
unfortunately we don't have any
exclusive cheerio options in the uk
here are all the cheerios you'll find in
the u.s but not in the uk
here we have the more fruity flavors
blueberry cheerios
apple cinnamon cheerios multi-grain
cheerios with strawberries very berry
cheerios chocolate strawberry cheerios
and fruity cheerios
is this supposed to be like their take
on fruit loops like healthy fruit loops
we have
pumpkin spice cheerios honey nut
cheerios medley
cinnamon cheerios
maple cheerios
frosted cheerios
chocolate peanut butter cheerios
cheerios oat crunch oats and honey
and cheerios oat crunch almond
we weren't able to get our hands on the
limited edition flavors toasted coconut
peach and banana nut i'm a big pumpkin
spice girl i think it's good
it smells like fall
also i don't even know if there's that
good or i'm just like it's pumpkin spice
i'm just automatically thinking it
smells and tastes good but
i think this would be amazing
[Music]
here are some british cereals which you
won't find in the us here are some
cereals you won't find in the uk
let's start with a us classic lucky
charms i do think they are a classic and
the marshmallows are really good they do
taste very artificial but they're
supposed to taste artificial and i stand
by that i've never had lucky charms
before i had to go to one of those
american shops on oxford street to get
one so are those all marshmallows all
those colorful things
it tastes like a marshmallow but it's
like crunchy marshmallows aren't
supposed to be crispy guys
i'd be lying if i said those weren't
good
that is good everything about the design
of this is just to like make a child go
oh my god i need this yes american
cereal boxes look like slot machines
that is by design so next up we've got
fruit loops another fruit loops is one
of those cereals you can eat dry because
they have enough flavor to them
colors are so fun
how fun that is
there's something's wrong with this one
danny used to taste like this
they used to use artificial red dye and
they switched to a natural one
they went too natural also never tried
these
i like the toucan guy he's cool
jesus christ
the smell of those
what is that
it smells like soap or like shower gel
yeah like a tropical a tropical shampoo
like a cheap body wash
no i don't like that
the same acidic smell that i got you can
taste that as well and that is not
something that you want with like milk
and finally
cat and crunch i think the other like
traditional sugary cereals are just
superior to it this is just so like
it doesn't offer anything you know
you can see where all the yellow five
and yellow six are going
they are crunchy as the name suggests
they're pretty good it's between these
are lucky charms fruit loops for me are
awful never stop eating those we'll
start with a personal favorite of mine
which is golden nuggets i'm a little
surprised you don't have these in the us
because the kind of uh advert campaign
was based around prospecting and the
gold rush so we've got like a little
mascot gold miner guy who i think his
name is like prospecting or something
like that
i do feel like they used to be brighter
than that yeah but uh they've got rid of
the catchphrase and also yeah demoted
the the mascot to the back of the pack
uh the catchphrase when i remember
growing up with these was they taste
yeehaw
okay they taste yeehaw what would be the
uk equivalent of that in america british
parliament flakes what'd you just say
parliament pops they taste jolly good
i don't think that tastes quite as
yee-ha as i remember from my childhood
but
still like a solid mid to low level of
yeehaw next up we got weetabix now i
personally love weetabix but i will say
it's quite a boring cereal if you
imagine the kind of like archetypal
really boring gray british breakfast
it's probably one of these it's
literally just compressed wheat
with a very small amount of sugar and i
think some enriched
vitamins and minerals like they have no
right to be as good as they are but they
are just good like i can't i can't
explain why as long as the milk is
really cold
so that you get the crisp that's
maintained
to me that's just pure nostalgia
so
we got
harry's
british cereal i'm very confused by this
i'm scared i'm gonna follow harry's
tutorial
okay
i don't think you can just call
something cereal because you're pouring
milk on top of it
and i feel like that's what's happening
here
like this kind of feels like if i were
to get a granola bar and pour milk on
top of it and i was going to be like oh
i'm eating cereal now
i don't want to say it tastes like
cardboard but it tastes like cardboard
my childhood was fruity pebbles i'm
sorry it was rainbows and unicorns and
magical flavors if you did want a
slightly more exciting version of
witavix then they do have flavoured ones
as well for example these are the
classic biscuits but banana flavoured
there are also some classic ones but
chocolate flavoured then they have a few
other options as well such as these ones
which are chocolate melts so it's kind
of like a weetabix outside layer but
then with like a little bit of chocolate
inside and these come with milk
chocolate or with white chocolate and
then finally maybe my favorite cereal
ever we to mix crispy minis these things
are incredible it's little bite-sized
versions of wheat bakes with a bunch of
chocolate chips in them honestly god
tear cereal this is supposed to be like
the treat version
food is supposed to make you feel better
our final uk solution for today are
wetos now not so much of a fan of these
myself they're kind of like cheerios and
that they're a ring shape however
they're a little bit bigger a little bit
like more puffy and airy and personally
i just don't love that because you know
when you're eating them with the milk
they go a little bit more soggy more
quickly yeah i'm sure some people like
them but not myself
this is a more realistic serving of 60
grams of frosted flakes if we do some
quick math we can figure out that the
nutrition for this is as follows
210 calories
zero grams of fat 53.4 grams of carbs
19.2 grams of which are sugar 1.62 grams
of fiber and 307 milligrams of sodium so
here's everything that's in 60 grams of
frosties in the uk 225 calories 0.36
grams of fat of which 0.06 grams are
saturated carbs 52.2 grams of which 22.2
grams are sugar fiber 1.4 grams and 232
milligrams of sodium the final thing to
note is that these values don't include
milk so in the states we have a few
different types of milk with varying fat
content skim milk which has zero percent
fat one percent milk two percent milk
and then whole milk which is around 3.25
fat for this example we're going to use
two percent milk in the uk we don't
refer to our milks by fat percentage
instead we call them skimmed
semi-skimmed and whole milk they're
around zero percent two percent and
three point five percent fat
respectively for this example we'll use
semi skimmed milk
so in the uk we also standardized the
colors of our milk so green is always
semi-skimmed blue is always whole milk
and red is skim milk whereas i spoke to
a few american friends and those are
just like all over the place depending
on where the country you are and it
seems like an absolute minefield so in
the u.s 100 milliliters of two percent
milk contains the following
50 calories 2.08 grams of total fat 1.25
grams of which are saturated 5 grams of
carbs of which 5 grams of sugar so
all the carbs of sugar and 52 milligrams
of sodium in the uk 100 milliliters of
semi-skimmed milk contains the following
50 calories 1.8 grams of fat of which
1.1 grams are saturated 4.8 grams of
carbs of which 4.8 grams are sugar and
40 milligrams of sodium our research
suggests that the average bowl of cereal
contains around 200 milliliters of milk
so these figures need to be doubled
then we can add those stats to our
realistic 60 gram serving and our final
tally looks something like this
so the same bowl in the u.s would
contain this
so the uk version is actually more
calorific and more sugary while the us
version has more fat total carbs and
sodium because of course we do the main
thing to watch out for here is of course
the sugar the recommended daily added
sugar intake for an adult is 50 grams
and this contains over 60 percent of
that
we're going to measure it out for you
now so you can see just how much sugar
is in one of these bowls
oh my god stop eating so much sugar
i feel like this is bad to say but this
isn't as much sugar as i thought there'd
be i thought that every more and like
sometimes i add more sugar to my cereal
so like
cereal is meant to be sugary i stand by
that so it's like i don't trust people
who eat like raisin bran raisin bran
people can't be trusted this is probably
about as much sugar i add to my coffee
so
look at okay this is a little bit more
sugar than i would do
my stomach hurts just watching this this
is genuinely good to me the 31.8 grams
of sugar in this bowl of frosties is
actually less than three american glazed
ring krispy kreme donuts so uh yeah i
guess you can just eat those for
breakfast instead here's the nutritional
info for a 60 gram bowl of honey
cheerios in the uk and here are the
values for a 60 gram honey nut cheerio
bowl in the u.s here's how the values
change if we add milk
so this bowl only contains around 16 of
your daily calories but
once again it's the sugar you need to
watch out for there's almost 60 of your
daily sugar allowance in here it's not
quite as bad in the uk at just 46 of
your daily sugar but that is still quite
a lot for your breakfast the good news
for the uk is that we somehow have 45
percent less sodium than the us bowl
[Music]
here are all the ingredients in frosties
in the uk
maize sugar barley malt flavoring salt
vitamins and minerals niacin iron b6 b2
b1 folic acid vitamin d and vitamin b12
yes we pronounce it vitamins not
vitamins
here are all the ingredients and frosted
flakes in the u.s milled corn sugar malt
flavor salt vitamins and minerals iron
niacinamide vitamin b6 vitamin b2
vitamin b1 folic acid vitamin d3 and
vitamin b12
the differences here are actually just
linguistic in practical terms those are
basically identical lists things get
more interesting when we move away from
classic frosted flakes
take these frosted flakes with crispy
cinnamon basketballs for example here's
the ingredients list for these
two things to watch out for here first
the yellow six this is a food coloring
which is used to give things a yellowy
orange color but you're unlikely to see
it on any ingredients list in the uk it
was flagged in a 2008 study as one of
six colorings that may be linked to
hyperactivity in kids if it's in a uk
food product it must come with a warning
that it may have an adverse effect on
activity and attention in children
the other ingredients watch out for here
is bht or butylated hydroxytoluene this
is an antioxidant which is used to keep
foods fresh outside of food use some use
it to treat herpes if that's not enough
to put you off there are also some
studies which have suggested that bht
causes rats to develop tumors
yay
there's actually very little evidence to
suggest that it could do the same to
humans but its use is still restricted
in places like australia and certain
companies such as general mills have
voluntarily taken steps to remove it
from all their products
here's everything in honey cheerios in
the uk
here's everything in honey nut cheerios
in the u.s these are pretty similar
lists with a few minor differences in
the uk we seem to put a bit more
emphasis on the grains with wheat barley
maize and rice all being involved
compared to just oats in the u.s
while we're doing a cereal episode we
may as well look at the milk used in
both the uk and the us you may have seen
certain headlines suggesting that u.s
milk is actually banned in the european
union that's not completely correct but
there are some differences to note which
do cause issues with imports the first
issue is due to something called somatic
cells these are basically just the white
blood cells which cows will produce to
fight infections when they get sick if
you have a higher somatic cell count in
your milk it's probably a sign that it
came from a less healthy cow the general
limit for a healthy cow is considered to
be around 100 000 cells per milliliter
with 200 000 getting towards mastitis
territory which is when the others get
infected for milk to be sold in the
european union the somatic cell count
can't be any higher than 400 000 cells
per milliliter but in the us it's almost
double that you guys have an upper
threshold of 750 000 cells per
milliliter which means that in general
you guys tolerate much sicker cows than
we do in the uk and the eu
not the sacred cows
i feel like every time we do one of
these it's basically just the uk being
like so you guys don't standardize
anything you don't regulate anything and
we're like
yeah
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between oreos in the uk and the us this
is food wars
hey everyone joe from food wars i will
not be partaking in this episode of
oreos because me and the team are busy
shooting a new season of food wars with
a new country that's right coming soon
to you it's going to be food wars us
versus
while we're working hard on that irene
of course is going to step in over there
in new york i will however stick around
for this episode to make smart alecky
comments because that's my brand
in the uk oreos come in four serving
sizes as a lunchbox pack of two as a
standard pack of 14 has a twin pack of
28 and has an open and share pack of 36.
in the us classic oreos come in six
serving sizes as a two cookie snack pack
as a six cookie snack pack as a king
size 10 cookie snack pack as a classic
pack of 36 cookies as a family size pack
of 48 cookies and finally as a party
size pack of 63 cookies
the cookies themselves are supposed to
weigh the same amount in both countries
11 grams we're gonna weigh one and find
out if that's true
12.4 grams let's see we're gonna do the
scientific method we're gonna we're
gonna test the second cookie
in case there's any disparities
yeah 11.4 you know i bet it's the
frosting
this one's 11.8 grams
yeah this one's 11.5 so the average
weight is 11.8 grams so our uk oreo
weighed 11.09 grams pretty much spot on
what they promised us the portion sizes
aren't the only thing that's different
between our oreos the us also has more
oreo size options there are the mini
oreos then the five stuff options oreo
thins classic oreo double stuff mega
stuff and then the most stuff
i didn't know the most stuff existed i
thought we ended it at double stuff we
kept going
i have an idea i don't know why they
haven't done this because the stuff is
what everybody wants at least in america
oreo needs to invent just stuff it is a
sandwich cookie stuff
stuff
stuff
check it out
just stuff oreos
[Music]
perfect that's all i want whereas our
options are minis
thins
plastic or double cream some reason we
call them double cream over here not
double stuff
how much stuff are we actually getting
let's dissect a classic oreo
2.52 grams we're committing to 3.2 grams
is it double stuff oreo actually giving
you double the stuff let's find out
oh look at that precision
so there's three point two so this if
there's a six that came to six point one
three for us oh they got a little bit
more that never happens
so in the uk double cream oreos actually
give you 143 more filling than the
classic oreo while a us double stuff has
87.5
more stuff than a classic oreo i want to
know how much the most stuff weighs
oh wow
this is excessive so the most stuff
weighs 11.2 grams which is a 250 percent
increase from the classic it's very
stable
[Music]
i'm gonna diy my own giant oreo i don't
know if it's gonna fit in my mouth but
harry makes the world's largest oreo
asmr 11.
it is
about three inches ish it's falling
apart much like me you know what has to
happen now i mean come on had to happen
had to happen harry this had to happen
there we go
[Music]
good you need the biscuit rick
yeah i i can i think i can see maybe uh
maybe all that stuffing at once is not a
good idea
here are all of the uk oreo products
that you won't find in the us here are
all the oreo products in the u.s you
won't find in the uk oreo lends its
brand name to a lot of products so we're
going to split this into sections
starting with the cookies that's nothing
compared to us we have 20 exclusive oreo
cookie flavors in the us we have two
exclusive classic oreos in the uk
starting with these ones which are
strawberry cheesecake i can't figure out
it's very good
then we have this one which is a
chocolate brownie batter flavor
the flavor of the chocolate filling kind
of gets lost in just the chocolate
cookie flavor peanut butter flavor cream
creme i do think some people put peanut
butter on their oreos maybe that's where
this came from the mega stuff
cause double stuff was simply not enough
for us
like honestly though i can appreciate
this because i always want more of the
frost thing but this is kind of
ridiculous isn't it they have
gluten-free oreos
lemon flavor cream oreos
this seems like a golden oreo with
lemon philly
it has the oreo structure but it's like
a whole completely different flavor
profile so it tastes really good
oreos are too popular in this country we
don't need this many flavors as we move
through this section you're going to
notice a bit of a cadbury theme because
cadbury and oreo seem to have partnered
up on quite a few products the first one
we have here is a cadbury coated oreo
now these are just basic oreos but then
covered in cadbury chocolate which as we
all know is much better than american
chocolate
it's very good but so bad for you then
after that we have these little bags of
oreo crunchy bites these come as either
classic
or as dipped versions i'm not really
sure how they differ from just classic
mini oreos so i'm going to open it back
and find out
is that not just a mini oreo that
they've rebranded
my left hand i'm holding an oreo crunchy
bite in my right hand i'm holding a mini
oreo the only notable difference is
maybe that the mini oreo has slightly
more filling i feel like this is just an
excuse to sell you maybe even less
stuffed mini oreos and a more expensive
price point companies can't get away
with this anymore now that food wars
exists chocolate hazelnuts
this is basically like if you put
nutella in an oreo caramel coconut
i think you would like this if you like
caramel chocolate marshmallow oh i think
this one does have something on the
biscuit that's different oh it's on the
inside i thought it would be the outside
that'd be more fun but
yeah you got the chocolate flavor but i
don't think the marshmallows really come
through is anyone even eating these
i've never seen a single person buy any
of these flavored ones so this feels
like a conspiracy we have the
java chip supposedly there will be
little chocolate chips
oh good this reminds me of like a
starbucks like java chip frappuccino
honestly dark chocolate the original is
just simply not chocolatey enough for
you
it matches the biscuit i'm actually
really excited about this one
they're olympic oreos
i'm one of those people who is like i
could have been an olympian my parents
had just loved me enough to you know
make it my entire life and force me to
like do it you know as if like that's
all it takes red white and blue layers
of cream with hopping candy oh these
layers are so uneven it's funny
you see this it's like
a while ago they had like special fourth
of july ones that had like sparklers or
something and it was wasted the same
thing with popping candy i feel like
they're kind of just reusing this oh
wait this is cool too it has the olympic
circles and the american flag the best
part about the olympics this year has
just been all the olympians on tick tock
and then also how funny it is that
everyone's like we are only patriotic
about how funny and hot they are
if any olympians are watching this i am
in fact single thank you when did food
wars become irene's dating app
she didn't say which olympians though so
like the canadian curling team's coming
after her so watch out
the next one which is still kind of a
cookie are these cadbury crunchy melts
oreo cream now these are kind of big
more traditional chocolate chip cookies
but then filled with a layer of oreo
cream also the packaging made me expect
a lot more of the oreo cream in the
middle there it's a very very thin layer
i'm really disappointed by that i was
had high hopes for these the texture of
the cookie is way off
salted caramel brownie oreos they're
really just turning every possible
dessert into an oreo at this point but
again i have never seen a single person
buy one of these if you are someone who
buys these please let me know because i
i think it's a conspiracy at this point
oh this one also has a double layer we
have a light brown layer and a dark
brown layer oh and then there's salt on
the biscuit they really elevated this
one it's like a gourmet oreo
i actually really like the salt on the
biscuit like comes together really
nicely again this is weird
carrot cake who thought of this carrot
cake's hard to get right
tastes like ginger which is like nice
icing so i actually like these but
that's because they don't taste like the
advertised flavor
i'm doing really bad shirley i'm trying
not to cry i think i'll be alive i don't
think i don't think the oreos will kill
me actually the oreos might kill me
i can't believe this is what's gonna
take me out it's gonna be the oreo
chocolate peanut butter pie
how many variations of chocolate peanut
butter do we need i will say they're
creative right it's not like they just
like blast it with flavors and it looks
the same at least they they look fun
i thought the oreos would make me feel
better
they made me feel worse
i was betrayed by the oreos
limited edition
s'mores graham
flavored cookies these are the
golden double stuffed oreos it's
literally non-chocolate version of a
regular oreo
i have an announcement to make golden
oreos are the best oreo that's right the
best these are the best look at me look
at me youtube commenters this is the
best oreo there is i have access to the
food insider youtube page i'll delete
your comments if you disagree with me
this is the best oreo
amazing so there's also three fudge
covered flavors classic
dark chocolate and mint there's also
these oreo thin bites in original and
white fudge
so these are basically mini oreos
covered in chocolate and of course the
oreo id which are customizable oreos we
decided to decorate it with white
sprinkles and put joe's face on it since
we missed him this episode i guess you
could call them durians
that's such a good idea why don't we
have that that's such a funny like party
gift like wedding favor just a lot of
potential there and i kind of wish we
had that look it's joe
i'm in la and i
eat food and do things and i have a
podcast i don't have a podcast i am the
last human being on the planet to have a
podcast comment below what my podcast
should be and who i should have on it
sorry joe i'm going to cut your face in
half
i think i would be saying this about
people there's just a lot of sugar just
too much sugar yeah i don't want these
joe you can have them
all right let's take a look at these
yeah these don't taste like oreos these
aren't very good sorry i taste terrible
apparently
then we have a section i'm really
excited for which is the frozen dessert
section we'll start with these which are
oreo ice creams with an oreo cookie
coating
[Music]
it's not the best ice cream i've ever
had very sweet and a bit like foamy
okay the cone is pretty good i'd say
this would maybe get better the more you
go down i think less of the ice cream on
the top and more of the cone the next
ice cream option is this one which is
the oreo ice cream with oreo biscuit
pieces in the uk we can also just get a
tub of oreo branded ice cream now once
which i've had before and can tell from
experience are very good these ones
which are the oreo ice cream sandwiches
then we're back to the cadbury
partnership with these cadbury coated
stick sandwiches our oreo desserts in
the u.s include breyer's oreo chips ahoy
ice cream and friendly's oreo cookies
ice cream cake
see this is a good dessert combo this
makes sense you're adding the oreos to
an existing thing
wow
ice cream cakes are always so hard to
cut
cake
and we weren't able to get these but
there's also klondike oreo ice cream
sandwiches good humor oreo ice cream
bars and good humor oreo cones then we
have a bunch of exclusive chocolate
options which are again mostly cadbury
this one is a dairy milk oreo sandwich
this one is also available in the form
of cadbury bites which is just
bite-sized pieces of their chocolate
bars then we're on to the one in the
middle which is the cadbury big taste
oreo crunch bar if milk chocolate isn't
your thing then they also have a cadbury
oreo white chocolate bar our final
chocolate bar is this one which is a
oreo milka max chocolate bar milker is
just a slightly different chocolate
brand here in the uk then we have a
couple of options for baked goods
including this oreo muffin and this oreo
donut
i mean if that counts as a filling again
a little bit underwhelming
and i ate that from the bottom like a
psychopath i don't do that all the time
this end bit looks slightly filled they
put it on the box it's supposed to look
like this
it's what you call false advertising
if you're gonna go for one of these
probably go for the muffin then we have
a couple more miscellaneous products
just to round up here are our
miscellaneous oreo items we have the
ready to bake pie crust and then the
instant pudding pie filling mix which is
cookies and cream flavored so these go
together this is the no-bake oreo
dessert kit which is basically these two
items in a box the first one is this
which is a cadbury oreo hot chocolate
powder now i'm fascinated by this one
because when i was buying it on the
website it had like loads of one-star
reviews saying it tasted horrible so
obviously we now have to try it i'm
going to use my colleague charlie's
wonderful mug which i think he got in a
charity shop which is celebrating the
marriage of a couple who we um we don't
know buki and rumi if you're watching
this i hope you had a happy marriage
four heap teaspoons of the powder into
your boiling water which is what i have
in here and we should end up with a
delicious oreo flavoured hot chocolate
so let's go
now just going to stir for about 40
minutes and then see what we end up with
protect me buki and woomy
wow okay
the immediate taste you get is chocolate
which you expect but then like a second
after every sip something just kind of
punches you in the face and it's not
very pleasant moving swiftly on from the
hot chocolate we have this which is an
oreo split pot yogurt yes it's
pronounced yogurt not yogurt get it
right do americans have muller corners
because i hate those all the time
growing up in the uk and this is the
exact style they've gone for basically
it's like a split pot thing where half
of it is yogurt and then a little corner
of it is a topping of some kind the idea
then being that you just crack this
and deposit all the toppings in this
really does take me back i would have
some kind of miller corner in like most
of my packed lunches when i was in
primary school
that's really tasty and the last but by
no means at least we have these which
are oreo o's now it's an oreo themed
breakfast cereal and it comes with these
chocolatey loops and then some vanilla
flavoured discs we have the oreo cereal
and these look like the uk version but
without the white puffs and then we also
have funfetti brownie mix
cake mix and frosting with oreo pieces
and lastly these are the oreos handy
snacks oreo cookie sticks and cream oh
my god no these look like you know those
cheese and cracker snack this looks like
the oreo version
oh my god oh it looks disgusting there's
like a pool of like oil or something
right there
here are all the ingredients in a
classic oreo in the uk
that makes a total of at least 18
ingredients possibly more if multiple
flavourings are used here are all the
ingredients in a classic oreo in the u.s
that comes to a total of at least 17
ingredients again dependent on the
flavorings used so uk oreo actually
contains more ingredients than the us
aria the uk has a few ingredients not
found in the u.s take sunflower lecithin
which they use in addition to soy
lecithin some people prefer to use
sunflower lecithin as it's extracted
naturally via cold pressing whereas soy
lecitin tends to be extracted using
chemicals such as acetone like a nail
polish remover
soybeans are also more commonly
genetically modified than sunflowers and
concerns over this have also driven
people away from soy and towards
sunflower as their preferred source of
lecithin in the u.s we use high fructose
corn syrup in our oreos compared to the
uk's glucose and fructose syrup you'll
see this in a lot of american products
as it's a cheaper alternative to actual
sugar as a result of the u.s producing a
huge amount of corn and tariffs on
imported sugar there's limited evidence
to suggest that high fructose corn syrup
is worse for you than normal sugar
nations which use it tend to have higher
rates of type 2 diabetes than those that
don't what about oreos with some more
controversial ingredients like birthday
cake for example in the uk we actually
call those birthday party oreos but they
are effectively the same thing in the uk
we color the sprinkles with spirulina
extract red beet juice and turmeric
extract whereas in the us we color our
sprinkles with yellow 5 blue 1 red 40
and red 3. fans of food wars will
recognize yellow 5 and red 40 as two
food colorings not often seen in the uk
if they are used in the uk manufacturers
have to add a warning that they may have
an adverse effect on activity and
attention in children we we love our
artificial and potentially dangerous
food colorings over here red three is
actually one i don't think we've seen
before on food wars it's otherwise known
as erythrazine and it's a dye used to
give foods a reddish pink color it's not
commonly used in the us with
manufacturers usually opting for a red
40 instead the reason for its low
popularity is its association with
certain health effects it was partially
banned in the u.s in 1990 after research
showed that it caused cancer in rats its
use is restricted in the european union
due to the same concerns while the
european food safety authority did say
that humans weren't at quite the same
risk of tumors that rats were they still
set a limit of 0.01 milligrams per
kilogram of body weight per day for
human consumption as a result the only
food that red 3 can be used in in the eu
is candied cherries it's not banned in
the u.s but it is restricted it can be
added to foods but it can't be put in
cosmetics or external drugs so you can
put it in your body but not on your body
other things to look out for in the u.s
include the carrot cake oreos which
contain caramel color according to the
state of california a byproduct of this
can cause cancer birth defects or other
reproductive harm
the uk's oreo is actually healthier in
every metric other than saturated fat
where the two are tied classic oreos
aren't too unhealthy except for the
sugar content you would only have to eat
11 us oreos to hit your entire daily
sugar allowance which is just under a
third of your daily calories what about
the least healthy oreo in each country
one in the uk it's the cadbury coated
oreo here's the nutritional information
for just one of them if you eat just
five of these you consume 98 of your
daily sugar and 55 of your daily
saturated fat and i'm pretty sure if i
started eating these i would be eating
more than five i release healthy oreo
it's the fudge covered dark chocolate
oreo five of these cookies will be 110
of your daily sugar allowance as well as
112.5 of your daily saturated fat i
don't know if i want to eat these these
are aggressive i feel like joe could
probably eat like the entire box i'll
try one
it says
i don't feel um just we don't need to
cover everything with chocolate
something about this seems wrong
it also is good it's very chocolatey it
tastes oh my god
the filling is chocolate too
joe can have these joe you can eat these
irene i don't want those don't send them
over here off to la
there
no thanks
hmm
okay yeah